une production du studio sfr bienvenue
aux sans filtre présenté par qasmi le
podcast on parle de se convaincre nos
invités datsyuk h 30 avec moi d'une
plante
ce week end c'est le free shipping week
end chez qasmi fake jusqu'à dimanche à
23h59
vous avez le shipping gratuit ajouté au
shopping gratuit notre code promo de 20%
qui le sans filtre en un mot puis vous
obtenez vraiment un gros des 140 sur les
quais ce que vous voulez faites pas les
tchékistes sur le site dans la
description du podcast c'est l'occasion
d'acheter vos caisses
sinon sur 28 ans en ce moment on
enregistrait beaucoup de podcasts sont
maintenant qui vont être dans les
prochains jours sur piquionne vallée
descente juste pour vous donner le goût
jonathan roy notre ami chanteur
catherine fournier femme politique
vincent vallières que vous traînez c'est
de me lever
stéphanie vendent lac qui sont deux
coanimateurs du podcast couple ouvert
on a fait le roy animateur humoriste
sophie brochu la pdg d'hydro-québec
olivier primo que vous connaissez yann
d'occupation double grèce et françois
lambert l'ex dragon et hommes d'affaires
incroyable donc dirigez vous sur pétrone
pour avoir accès à ces bottes casque
sinon c'est un monde d'hommes cette
semaine on parle de douleur on parle de
blessures
on parle de physiothérapie avec deux
physiothérapeutes ariel desjardins
charbonneau et ses vins cet amour qui
sont propriétaires de cliniques qui sont
qui enseigne aussi à verser montréal la
physiothérapie des spécialistes de la
douleur vraiment l'idée on a pris un
petit peu plus c'est quoi la douleur
comment ça fonctionne en fait c'était
une émotion en fait on en est là dessus
c'était super intéressant moi j'ai
appris plein de choses on a déboulonné
aussi beaucoup de mythes sur la santé
sur la douleur sur le corps humain
c'était vraiment super le fun pak et
amusez-vous bonne écoute pillés ou
encore yes juste avant on va les
remercier nos commanditaires
le podcast est présenté par ou ardeurs
bio qui font des produits alimentaires
innovants pour chien donc si vous avez
un chien si vous connaissez des gens qui
ont des chiens wilder amy lieu est une
excellente manière de nourrir votre
chien et leurs produits sont
hypoallergéniques son éco responsable
ils sont faits à partir de protéine
alternative et s'est fait ici au québec
qu'est ce qu'on entend par protéine
alternative d'après plusieurs choses
appelle des gâteries sont faits à base
de grilles ont donc on transforme des
grillons en nourriture pour votre chien
et votre chien en raffolent y aussi des
gâteries à base d'algues et de gaspésie
et de pulpe recyclés et à sion aussi de
la nourriture à plus de gâteries de la
nourriture pour chiens à base d'insectes
et de la nourriture pour chiens à base
de poisson éco responsable c'est ce qu'a
vu ce que ça veut dire en fait c'est qui
pêche la carpe asiatique qui doit être
pêchés pour contrôler les fonds marins
dont le travail avec des pêcheurs nord
américain
pour s'occuper de farceurs d'une façon
durable et responsable ils viennent de
lancer une nouvelle gamme de nourriture
pour chien vous avec la coved ya
beaucoup de monde qui qui sentaient
seuls qui ont décidé d'adopter un chien
et apprend la nourriture pour ces chiens
là pour ça être sûrs qu'ils ont tous les
nutriments nécessaires pour leur
croissance de coin de rue
et oui euh pardon vient de lancer cette
gamme de nourriture là on a un code
promo pour vous autres pieds le sf 20 et
pour 20% de rabais sur leur site web
mon chien sauve le monde point ca donc
allé voir ce on encourage les
entreprises locales puis vous allez
adorer
mais vous votre chien c'est la lose you
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
c'est parti
merci merci les dates league les
écouteurs optionnelle c'est juste sont
émus pour des projets d être par exemple
on s'entend bien quand même
parfait merci d'être là
sa déviation c'est super d'avoir cette
discussion là parce que les autres anges
a en fait déjà parler pour moi pour toi
et moi j'arrive dans l'âge où est ce que
je commence à avoir merdé place fiscaux
à samedi rocky faudrait que j'aie
entretiennent ce comme du monde le sait
entretenir c'est comme tu as comme comme
ta voiture le temps d'aller faire un
petit check up
parce qu'il avant je me disais béton
petit faisant font vraiment blessé sac à
main la vingtaine c'est comme deux
semaines plus tard il s'en pu l'être
mais là ça commence à sentir le poids
exact c'est ça est ce que l'enfant
pourrait commander toutes les toutes les
directions le est-ce que en fait
pourquoi est-ce-que large est un est un
parallèle avec les blessures qui
arrivent plus mettons pourquoi est ce
que c'est quelque chose qui arrive plus
puisque j'y suis juste parce que j'ai
l'impression c'est la réalité
j'ai une bonne nouvelle le
vieillissement justifie patrick su
allier dollars c'est davantage
l'expérience fait que comme personne
vieillissante avance en âge on s'est
blessé à répétition dans notre vie fait
que j'expérimente pas mal la même chose
j'ai franchi le cap des 40 ans je
commençais à payer le prix c'est comme
si ta capacité d'adaptation il attesté
de plus en plus les années avancent avec
notre job à nous autres c'est d'éviter
cette espèce de vases le conte aura
rempli pendant une quarantaine d'années
pour faire en sorte justement qu'ils
étaient moins mal ultime une quête
d'infos les blessures qu'on a justement
traîne une tragi lite est lié à ses
blessures luc ferry qui font qu'ils
peuvent revenir plus facilement vraiment
de la même façon que le compte était
cicatrices sont encore kaki ça disparaît
jamais complètement sacré pas toujours
des problèmes
je serai pas une fragilité passe ton
corps n'est pas fragile jeudi
juste que ce camp un château de cartes
que tu accumules comme année il peut
s'écrouler mais c'est pas ce poste
rajouté en soit c'est une trés pompe une
prédisposition à ok c'est un peu plus
facile que tu fasses des votes déborder
le vase
parce que tu le remplir du helmand mais
on n'a plus qu'à un pas gigantesque qui
réussiront jamais à remplir c'est pour
tout le monde non plus que des douleurs
ok comme ie qui effectue une usure
finalement qu'on a cumulé que les tapis
camani a pu franchir un seul mais j'aime
pas le mot jours qu'est ce que ça fait
référence à deux lettres dégénérescence
un kit pour qt se faisait can dance je
commencerai discret graduellement ses
pales que ce post c'est le tas capacité
à tolérer un stress de plus physique
dans ta vie fait que c'est comme la
cicatrice de plus que le ton corps il
accepte moins ne sait pas nécessairement
social usuriers du jour mais l'usure et
pas nécessairement ceux ci à la douleur
qui équipe parce que sinon ce serait
condamner avoir mal si c'était l'usure
ces calculs c'est paul qui exercent et
ceux qui quittent des fois on fait un
peu de lyrisme
c'est à dire que on se dit ah ben il est
partagé fillon mal c'est normal passante
âgée mais c'est parce que je sais que je
terminerai pas avoir mal peu importe
l'âge chez toi tu veux pas que c'était
les douleurs nécessairement peu importe
la chanteuse ph est passible 4 avant de
l'enregistrer le csmme les accepte pas
conçu pour m'en sortir
sauf que moi j'aime c'est j'écoute et je
mens par rapport à qu'est ce qui est le
facteur un des facteurs les plus rapides
comme du de la perte d'autonomie puis du
vieillissement des personnes âgées en
fuite le puits c'était sous val l'arrêt
de la mobilité ou la perte de mobilité
étant la chose qui faisait que met-on
lot et un petit une personne n'attend de
75 85 et qui tactile père m'amenait y
arrive un autre mot ou une blessure puis
le thé dans tacheté sur ta chaise
pendants existant pile là c'est là que
ça porte un coup et il a dit je
comprends que je comprends que la
corrélation entre alger et douleur est
pas est pas normal on ne serait pas là
fort sauf que c'est aussi là que ça
devient encore plus important de
régler ses problèmes puis est ce que
j'imagine la réponse est oui mais que la
solution est beaucoup plus en prévention
tout au long de sa vie que de guérir
quand ça arrive on va définir prévention
parce qu' il n'existe pas vraiment de
prévention en douleur physique parce
qu'on n'est pas capable de prédire qui
aujourd'hui avec un problème va avoir
mal plus tard on y regarde de près dire
se fait par prévention ce qu'on pourrait
vouloir dire si les douleurs que de
négliger quand avait 26 ans puis que tu
prennes fois de temps en temps après une
grosse journée de ski c'est celle là tu
devrais faire traiter probablement si tu
voulais augmenter les chances de bien
guérir fait la prévention ça passe plus
par s'occuper des problèmes qu'on a eu
en temps et lieu mais de dire je vais
aller faire une fois par mois un check
up pour faire de la prévention ça la
littérature pour garder de dire ça
existe lord marketing que scientifiques
qui s'intéressent à fait techniquement
c'est ça le check-up mensuel il change
rien c'est au point un problème que tu
detec exact il ya pas une personne type
le potimarron vous dans vos bureaux y
oppose deux candidats le groupe
c'est finalement qui viennent souvent
soit juste polis des athlètes lautier
tue un groupe que plus qui +77
développer des douleurs des problèmes ou
ça te plus touchés importés qui en
traite comme de tous les patients ce qui
bouge beaucoup plus bas pas ce qui bouge
qui bouge pas beaucoup plus calmes abbas
qui bouge pas beaucoup
ok taquet enfin bouger moyenne à 7 et
une commande à lui à bercy en fait c'est
cadré mais vieux qui est un peu de tout
mais pas trop en général c'est bon un
kick équipe réputée pour la prévention
en fait il n'ya pas de la préparation
physique j'ai reçu votre vision et votre
par mois pour ça et ce facteur qui ont
députés ont prouvé que tu peut prévenir
des douleurs sans bouger un peu mais pas
trop oui ces avancées sociales
importantes le toit puis pas manger de
kraft mais attendez ça le reste rien eu
il y aurait une miraculée pas un
physique lui devant le programme de
prévention pour petit of majeur est à
dix personnes toutes les russies cela
fait qu'on remarque une corrélation
entre les gens qui ont fait ça
social puis des gens qui ont moins de
douleur capoter un oui mais qu'est ce
qui est plus pauvres c'est certainement
pas de cause à effet mais ton où ça peut
se cause à effet ou c'est juste une
corrélation conditions jean le jeu je
pense qu'ils ont un mode de vie plus
plus plus actif plus simple les facteurs
psychosociaux les facteurs associés à la
façon dont je perçois la douleur par
exemple ce qu'on voit c'est que ceux qui
ont un réseau de soutien facture est ce
que c'est parce que tous les capacités
t'exprimer que talent après la capacité
d'être compris par d'autres personnes
que ce ne sont pas seuls à vis des
choses c'est ce soutien le contribuerez
à ton succès face à des douleurs musculo
squelettiques fait que c'est
impressionnant
la corrélation exacte banque de l'étude
je pourrais pas de là relate exactement
reste un facteur réducteur de succès en
douleur physique le fait d'avoir un
support social
le fait d'avoir un conjoint c'est près
du temps d'un plus grand succès qui sait
même pas dit à david de la mort on sort
on
non mais c'est vrai on sort de physio de
médecine site vraiment intéressante à
horgen zh et ont pris des étudiants des
années le champion en l'occurrence
j'aurai 25 en tout 40 désir de rejouer
puis on regarde et ils ont suivi jusqu'à
encore maintenant arrêter des gens comme
90 actuellement de dire regarde bien à
chaque année ils prennent le train de
données sociodémographiques de poids de
6 la santé que ceux qui mangent tout ça
bieber on regarde le tournoi de taux de
mortalité voici ses plus importants mais
qu'est-ce qui prédisent inc qui va
mourir jeune ou plus jeunes puis c'est
le support social qui est le facteur
moderniste review bas de toutes les
affaires possibles de la santé peut
mesurer un nom c'est fou ça c'est ainsi
probablement se met le l'idée que s'il
ya quelque chose qui va pas tu peux plus
le verbaliser à quelqu'un de talent dont
on ne sait pas comment ça fonctionne un
peu comme les exercices ses droits à
dire de mes exercices on sait pas
exactement comment ça fonctionne pour
aider les gens qu'est ce que tu sais ce
que vous que vous donnez que vous
écrivez nous
d'habitude quand je fais quand il fait
ça ça vaut mieux après mais on sait pas
pourquoi mon exercice généraux voilà
quelqu un que j ai cru que l'on fait de
voir pas un exercice spécifique qui
concrètement que l'exercice général ben
hodges ya eu un impact énorme qui vaut
mieux un anneau jean on sait pas
exactement pourquoi il vaut mieux c'est
une activité cardio vasculaires tout le
renforcement c'est juste de s'activer le
devoir d' amis indiens exigent le
problème c'est sur un cagnard aide les
douleurs reviennent mais on a un paquet
que c'est grâce à ce fait qui trouvent
leurs propres solutions et d'en avoir
créé des problèmes aussi avec ce c'est
là que ça se passe
est-ce que vous avez remarqué dans vos
clients des gens qui ont débuté le
training camp c'est devenu plus
accessible mais ton avec des cadeaux
fitness de ce monde voit ce que le tu
peux y aller puis y'a pas de coach sur
place il ya personne qui t'apprend les
mouvements est-ce que vous avez vu une
croissance dans les problèmes liés à
l'accès technique dans ces 20 dernières
années
moi je dirais que j'ai vu j'aime
beaucoup le yoga le pilates à sa mini ce
j'ai vu une influence j'ai vu une canne
la popularité de tous augmenté c'était
la course à pied une mode qui a commencé
le nombre d'années enfin quand de 1h
maman de gens blessés en course à pied
c'est pas qu'ils restent bas tu peux
commencer de façon regarde c'est
peut-être le seul parce que tu commences
de façon progressive en général ça va
bien puis tu respectes limite ça vaut
bien c'est juste quelqu'un de même
atteindre un marathon sans pratique
souvent ça marche pas mais c'est avec le
pilates oeil sur une quinzaine d'années
quand ça a commencé et plein de gens qui
s'irrite en faisant sur le yoga ou six
traitements à un groupe qui dirige aussi
d'être super bon il y avait aussi fini
dans une position peu président met
encore les pneus soient incapables de le
faire
factions seront le plus vu le djing je
pourrais dire que je vois une relation
parce qu'il est gentil
c'est une machine très mal d'en faire
une autre est en général les gens sont
capables d'automne du lait mais quand tu
es pris dans ta position tu réussiras
ferait augmenter pris dans sa position
j'aurais jamais pensé que qu'on se dit
que le yoga pour être plus dangereux que
pascal parce qu'il ya des platters
pourtant j'aurais imaginé que c'était
quand même d'où pour le corps mais
effectivement que si tu veux tester chez
pata souplesse jusqu'à sa limite ça ce
qui arrive un accident
exactement si tu testes pas encore apte
et limite ça reste doux mais comme james
et espère encore à la date limite des
règles fixées c'est comme les coaches
qui qui pousse au maximum derrière la
tête
en tant que coach de était de 2-2 par le
coach m
comme des pros vigueur qui pousse au
maximum leurs participants c'est aussi
ça peut causer des blessures similaires
qu'est ce que vous pensez des trending
sait comment capes a donc pas su
maximale ses rites
non les mettons faire un exercice mais
sans échec ne jamais se rendre jusqu'à
l'échec
moi quand j'ai quand je nageais la fin
de ma carrière c'est ce que je fais ici
je me rendais jamais à devoir me faire
spots et akon pour c'est vraiment à la
corde corps de corde le faire des
directs sont 80% mais ton mais qui me
permettait à rhodes meilleure amplitude
de mouvement puis de juste jamais
développé de troubles liés à ce que je
me rappelle que je cache benchs et puis
je suis je me faisais spots et à la fin
il y avait des flashs des pcaa de bouger
mon épaule même au musculairement et il
est en fin de carrière
si c'est exact x je te dirais un
kinésiologue c'est peut-être plus adapté
à revoir cette question de nous comme
futé un kinésiologue ses études et a
percuté deux métiers avec nous autres
avec ses spécialistes des entraînements
fact et qui prennent des gens qui ont
pas mal
pire encore meilleur nos patients qui
ont mal puis on les ramène à la normale
tu veux mais pour qui permettait de voir
qu'un dialogue pour gagner encore de
tous aux taxes ta question pour toi
c'était de s'accuser là que quelques
mois qui pourrait te répondre on passe
quand on met bien sûr le but qui a envie
de spots et qui a envie de se pousser au
maximum 7 10 permet de le faire moi
c'est ça que c'est une chance qu'on me
dise bien c'est fini
too bad de 15 heures des cheveux gris
bains ont été reprochés
c'est l'idée encore une fois c'est que
moche programme de border line
directement j'ai pas vu tant que des
gens qui m'ont vanté le changement
d'entraînement pour les cages va plus
soft mais on les rend capables temps
mentionné aussi un autre un autre acteur
aussi qu' une corrélation avec la
douleur qu'ils mangent et de crocs comme
comme tu le dis ils puissent e s qui on
le sait mais ton qu'est ce qui se passe
dans le casque parce que le construire
génèrent moins bien qui peuvent guérir
rapidement ce qui encore une fois j'ai
pas de nutritionnistes mais de ce que je
comprends c'est les aimes tu peux tu
présenter la guérison possible de ton
corps mais c'est rare qu'une instruction
parfaite parfaite parfaite doit
augmenter performance mais encore une
fois que c'est pas mon domaine c'est
jeudi parce que j'étais resté à cela
c'est ce que je comprends pas que ça
c'est juste
picross un acronyme au québec ckoi
d'aider la croix puis en fait quand tu
en consomment de façon que c'est ça qui
fait que dans une alimentation
équilibrée aucun problème ségou dit pas
autre chose qui dit le dans une entrevue
jean est gelée vraiment échappé pendant
le confinement tlc si je l'ait vraiment
échappé je tombais ou plus beau que
jamais tomber j'ai mangé du point
elle est si dure la vie j'ai bu de
l'alcool j'ai mangé du genre plutôt le
disait justement avec l'âge de paris vi
et qu'on remplit le var se remplit peu à
peu le plus en plus puis à fond vous
votre job c'est d'aider les gens à vis
des semences la seule image un peu de
données ou grosses et l'aubade regrossir
de voir ce qu'est le travail sur les
deux fronts en même temps qui est
fatigué mais tant qu'on commence par
essayer de vider le vase c'est comment
qu'on fait c'est encore ça va dépendre
du diagnostic de chacun
mais de façon générale la la mécanique
normale du corps est altérée en général
pour rempli dont force fait quelqu'un
est mécanique fonctionne pas comme fou
on pourrait prendre exemple dangereux
que mal à l'épaule qui attaquent dans
l'eau bien à ce moment-là exact la
coordination est pas adéquat de
mouvement se fait pas de façon adéquate
ce mouvement reste eu le répète depuis
mille fois par entraînement
éventuellement ces lieux où la dose
cumulatif en sorte que traverse des
barreaux des bornes qui fait notre job
c'est de modifier cette mécanique le
fokker tackett façon d'y arriver mais
utilement si on veut résumer à sucer de
d'éliminer ou de minimiser le mauvais
mouvement qui est responsable de ce
stress mécanique ne seront pas seulement
le stress mécanique vaut faire déborder
le vase on va faire en sorte que tissu
pour être ce pourrait à ce moment les
deux fragilisés pourraient à ce moment à
le présenter des 5 12 heures dans le cas
mettant de la course à pied kadri
mettons simon mouvement serait bon je
passe en scène blessés hier encore une
fois ci dessus il va de façon
progressive pour pau surchargé qui su
par ses titulaires demain matin soit
faire un 21 km put jamais couru mais
l'eau
c'est ce serait équivalent de d'essayer
d'aller dénicher 300 livres liveris
d'arriver quelque chose sont
probablement de la façon dont tu bouges
mais un stress sûreté dessus si tu
bouges toujours toujours de la même
façon mais stress est toujours bien en
place
sinon on voit ce que y avoir une
augmentation la douleur de sensibilité
technitoit z de fer sait déjà qu'ils
vont
toujours dans un patin de changer leurs
patins temporairement pour qu'ils
allaient de stress soit parti qui fait
mal puisqu'elle met juste ailleurs puis
à mettons que le mouvement est bon la
répétition le je pense maintenant à moi
j'ai côtoyé beaucoup de nageurs
d'ultramarathon le tchèque les traces du
lac saint jean à 32 km dès 8 heures de
temps et y ait des gens avec vraiment
une qui sont entrés de façon privée
s'est fait que c'est pas il se lance pas
dans l'eau pour faire le 30e kilomètre
l'ayons fait des semaines à 100 kg
octobre et au plus tôt mais a sorti six
même s'ils ont une technique impeccable
puissant capable justement de faire des
semaines à 100 kg sans se blesser
assortie d'une traversée comme ça leur
évolution sauter le t on vraiment mal
pendant dix semaines des jours après on
y respecte ses épaules puis même si le
mouvement est bon j'imagine que par une
usure aussi éventuellement ben 10
c'est la course à l'opposition de la
norges on a dépendu de la cause dans
notre évolution pour sauver la norges
peut-être un peu moins au fait qu'est ce
que nos épaules sont faites pour faire 5
kilomètres de morges
je possède son impôt gym pour la
connaissance pour répondre à la question
mais si on prend le jogging il semble y
avoir des études qui ont soulevé la
possibilité qu'après 40 km par semaine
de course
je commence à avoir des effets néfastes
je pense au niveau cardiovasculaire même
les qui semblait avoir quand même une
dose de ce que tu es capable de faire
endurer à ton corps va te lis gilles
trois nageurs ont découvert la dose qui
se méprenant quelqu'un qui se contente
d'une compétition normale y ont pas mal
non encore une fois une question de dose
ou est ce que comme tu dis fort romain
qui va y avoir une forme d'usure et puis
quels sont les blessures les plus
fréquentes que vous avez maintenant de
la population générale
je te dirai ça dépend vraiment de notre
clientèle et j'ai fini par développer
une clientèle des gens qui avaient plus
complexe que ce soit même clientèle que
quelqu'un qui travaille dans un centre
sportif parce que il ya des nageurs qui
sont dehors du tennis ou de la
couverture de ce recueil de sa place à
bord des vaisseaux h et i fakty ça
dépendra ouest du travail
j'ai dû commencer le bas du dos en
lambert le cou les épaules des genoux cc
c'est ce qu'on voit c'est pas notre pain
et notre beurre 4 à notre clientèle se
situe là dedans des sondés 74 2 6 2 6 4
quatre échangeurs parce que c'est des
régions qui sont les plus sollicités
dans le mouvement général ou qui sont
plus fragiles
c'est là où est ce que on a moins de
variations de patton c'est quand je dis
tantôt t on mettre cette place si
toujours un passé fait mal puis si on
change de place ça fait moins mal
ben les personnes qui ont toujours de
même pas atteints des mêmes postures un
mouvement et l'avoir m puis on se rend
compte que dans ces régions de on
remarque souvent sow puis on pourrait
nommer la chaise comme étant des
éléments c'est celui que je dise parce
que à 20 on était endormie pas de rayer
d'un sur de la roche dans des positions
du crochet jadis bull et on était soit
accroupi soient couchés à terre soit
debout la chaise est venue modifier
notre mode de vie de façon assez
importante pour modifier le
fonctionnement du camp fait que des
adaptations qui est que notre corps
subie à cause la chaise qui vont mener
des douleurs lombaires en premier des
doigts sauf qu'en deuxième pourquoi pas
des preuves des pôles parce que notre
posture change qui c'est 70% des gens
présentent à peu près la même posture à
ceux ci par exemple à l'approché
artistique et quitte donc c'est ça on a
parlé de douleurs de de gens très actifs
l'autre font du sport de haut niveau par
exemple mais vous avez parlé aussi
plutôt des gens actifs dans la douleur
des gens qui mettons qu'il ferait des
digues gros journée de travail à six qui
ferait pas vraiment excité physique ces
gens là vous développez les douleurs
d'enfant ouais c'est pas parce qu'ils
sont immobiles ou qui n'ont pas
d'activité physique c'est parce qu'ils
sont dans des positions sont prolongées
sans changer de position fait que cette
variation dans les positions comme
d'ariel et sur une question de changer
de position de façon plus régulière puis
d'éviter la position assise prolongée
qu'est ce qui fait qu'on se rend pas
compte c'est qui qui comme trop tard
moment qu'on se rend compte qu'on ne
connaît ni leur a fait le thé parce que
quoi qu'on n'a pas des signaux plus
rapidement qui nous dit hier un problème
aussi ont-ils mettant moi par exemple
j'ai tout le temps une tendance à être
quand même un peu les épaules par en
avant plan un peu le douar qui prône
avant tout ma jeunesse ma mère me dit
cet open - trois doigts même temps comme
voici alors dit à droite mais qu'est-ce
qui fait c'est sans doute pas bon pour
moi cette posture lui mais qu'est ce qui
fait que naturellement j'ai envie mais
me positionner comme ceux ci c'est pas
bon mais en fait il n'y a pas vraiment
de bonne ou de mauvaise posture
ce qui est important de savoir si c'est
à seule posture dans ta vie pierre
mathues de bds à dos rond
je veux te fais tu te ramasses pour
prendre de court d'autres pistes
étudiées d'études mandat dans le milieu
du dos ben si tu es toujours pierre
bardes auront pu prendre une autre
posture dans ta vie des ta posture
habituelle deviez pragmatique jusqu'à
temps que tu te blesses dans ce
mouvement d'eau mais si tu te blesses
pas le fait d'être l'otan comme ce n'est
pas décent pragmatique que ça augmente
les chances des bleus sous ses
inventions des blessures quand t'es pas
capable de varier ton mouvement de taper
sur fait les gens qui sont toujours avec
classe oui mais si des fois t'es comme
ça comme ça des fautes comme ça tu peux
avoir grave mais ça fait pas vraiment
partie de notre vie le changer de
posture dans ses méthodes en aux heures
de travail avec un cerveau normal
faisceau spontanément avec un cerveau
normal votre faire varier de pollution
justement parce que tu es sans cerveau
des mécanismes qui vont un peu tu avais
retirent mais on n'est pas beaucoup
avoir des cerveaux normaux kerry micks
pour ce conte est un paquet par exemple
les 90% des gens 80 90 % des gens qui
vont avoir mal au dos une fois dans leur
vie
ça laisse pas beaucoup de gens normaux
non c'est au moment où on se parle d'une
personne sur cinq est mal au dos ça
qu'on est pas mal après être normaux
mais pour ta posture spécifiquement de
prendre la copier la posture de
quelqu'un dans ta famille on pourrait
dire ton père ou sa mère fatma qui le
disons production pas
des fois il ya beaucoup de mimétisme
copie la posture de ceux qui nous
entourent c'est fascinant l'autre chose
c'est que ta posture pour l'instant ne
menace pas ta survie fait pourquoi il a
changé c'est ton cerveau il vaut mieux
garder en vie puis à la regrettée
reproduire c'est qu'on intéresse la base
ou fake ta posture pour l'instant a fait
capoter capacité de survie effectué la
change repos et un cerveau pathologique
conserve la pollution problématique et
tamines éventuellement arrêter de sortir
des tas pulsions problématique c'est
cela les autres problèmes à fait ce que
j'allais poser comme prime prochaine
question mais ça m'a mené à force d'être
tout le temps comme ce jeu développé une
douleur on dirait que rendu le sont
encore plus difficile d'en sortir parce
que les zones comme établie en patins
depuis puis peut-être qui justement ça
va être quand je vais être comme ça que
je - centre du globe et ce même endroit
les gens roulante
c'est plus difficile par toi même y'a
pas des mécanismes réels qui vont
t'aider à t'en sortir tout seul c'est
les mécanismes qu'on connaît qui nous a
attirés guérison fait que tu croupis
guéri si à l'intérieur du blitz tubéry
une fois que la guérison des tissus est
fini il n'y a pas vraiment de mécanismes
qui vaut qu'ils existent pour t'aider à
modifier des postures par toi même pour
aider à modifier des mouvements parfois
même par des fautes adoptent des
mouvements néfastes 5 les cerveaux et
bauguil justement votre sens des 50
ahmad c'est comme les mecs comme ça va
le virus dans ton ordi régis une base en
franchise on est de la faire pipi
d'enfant le rôle d'ysé haussé de
déprogrammer exa le seul mot qu'on
utilise le plus un traitement c'est ce
programme et vous mettiez la façon que
le cerveau du système jusque là tu
refuses des articulations
moi je m'étais déjà faire en faisant ce
jeu deadlift
je m'était vraiment fait mal au bas du
dos mais ça avait donné juste sur un bon
couple
aussitôt je le sentais puis j'ai rien
fait pour plus apprécié est apparue une
douleur super aiguë dans mon genou puis
jetez plus capable de fabriquer que fly
sous l'eau puis le mât compétition
arrive et moi je paniquais aps le chalet
voir le physio au rouge et or qui maudit
rituel parce que moi je comprends je
comprends pas si je faisais même plus de
course à pied je faisais du vélo
stationnaire mon cardio pour éviter de
blesser d'inviter le maître des chocs
pour rien plus tu comprends pas et s'est
rien passé je rien fait de différent
pleut me demander il ya quelque chose
qui s'est passé dans les derniers mois
et supplée le che pas plaisir pencher
fait que c'est vrai a mené j'ai fait un
faux mouvement au jam j'ai eu mal de dos
pendant deux jours mais comme c'est
parti après mais lui il m'a dit c'est
tout ce que ton temps corps avait besoin
pour compenser d'un mort le jeune homme
est allé en fait on appelle ça une
douleur référé une peur référé ça veut
dire qu'il ya quelque chose qui
souffrent dans mon corps mais que c'est
frime ailleurs juste qu'il ya dans
cerveau de narcy ce qu'on va y eu avec
deux parties de grand soir de l'endroit
puis de l'ofc avons dans le cerveau mais
après le même chemin que ça vous sais
pas si ça viendra pas de gauche a pas de
droite mais c'est passé 22 ton dos ou de
ton genou
le code est plus classique de l'affairé
c'est quand on voit une frise de type en
question est trop froide thomas dans le
front ouais bah moins de bottes à six
matchs par ton front s'est empalé kireta
nador à ton front bas en tout cas à toi
ton dos rippel doit-on genou puis mais
ce n'était pas non à ceux de ce que je
comprenais pas ce que ce que tu dis là
est une bonne explication la merci de ce
que moi je comprenais même temps de ce
qui me disait c'est que
pour les semaines après parce que droite
est pas directement au même moment c'est
que pour les semaines après l'une dit
que mon corps se seraient protégés en
faisant un mouvement qui était pas
normal c'est l'autre mon genou est et y
mettons en faisant mon mon monde et de
lift que j'essayais de me protéger le
dos fait je mettais plus de pression sur
mon genou de ce qu on pense évidemment
modifiant le mouvement cesse peur mais
la plupart du temps ce que je disais
tantôt section savent où ça n'existe pas
ces mécanismes pour le frais les gens
croient aux compensations fait souvent
été utilisé comme vulgarisation pour que
les gens acceptent l'idée qu'on traite
l'eurusd pourrait dès lors nous nous
mettons mai mais ça reste que des
mécanismes qui te permettre de t'en
sortir pour protéger ton dos il y en a
beaucoup fait que les chances que ton
cerveau ce design joue au scrabble et
les genoux pour pirlo a mal au dos fait
que le concept de compensation qui me
jugent moi je sais comment l'as tu t'es
fait mal la fête l'autre qu'on pense
l'autre bord puis le silex ça
n'existerait pas ça arrive des fois mais
faut être capable de l'objective et avec
nos vieux taxis tu te penches tout
croche pied et wigan grandes pages de
toute voie ça c'est une compensation
puissant arrive des fréquentations
mais si visuellement je peux te dire que
tu bouges différemment c'est prend pas
d'augmentation c'est si dur que ça
existe pas que ses preuves en plus il
doit référé parce que la passion dans
tout et bbc en photo ddm par exemple si
tu avais d'autres eaux arctiques quand
tu dors que quelques 400 emplois mais
quand turnage ton dos il peut être
encore arkema deviendra cc ton dos puis
même si thomas et au dos la doit à ses
crimes dans genou c'est le même
mouvement dans ce trou dans lequel nous
mettons des merdes de lentilles
florestine ce mon genou ça servait à
rien
or ouais mais ça c'est si fausse de
penser que les genoux mettons
probablement physiquement il rien y'a
pas de problème avec le genou comme tel
finalement fait que pour certaines
douleurs quelque part piqué 7,7 baptiste
corot a complètement corrects par
torrentfreak
il ya dessus des corrélations en des
parties du corps qui seraient dans la
danse dans la douleur référé plus
souvent lié team et onze type pour que
pour que mon dos passe par le jeu nous
le soumettons mon épaule qui peut pas
séparer la cause d'embargo médiatisée
affaire comme ceux qui sont répertoriés
comme étant lié à y en a plein en fait
mais c'est tout pas région c'est par
exemple les motards
ça vient de la région cervicale fait que
ta région cervicale ont un problème qui
a décidé de s'exprimer viol un trait
d'humour au visage du pardon de la en
arrière de l'oeil qui venait d'être
région cervicale
tu peux avoir douleur à l'épaule tournée
de la région cervicale l'estomac peut
référer la région thoracique
tu peux avoir un problème de coudes pour
faire en sorte que ce soit en dehors ou
du poignet fait que chaque région aussi
particularités et puis on voit tellement
nombre qu'on est capable d'identifier
coin une sensation de gonflement narnia
du genou c'est bien sûr un doudou
frétille un taquet la fin comme ça mais
grosso modo ce n'est que du pouce ne de
couple vraiment dans le bras de
dobermann en jambes grossièrement
grossièrement ces sommes étaient il faut
pas dire que chaque duel au genou vient
bidos pas vrai il ya des droits le week
end une usine mais quand s'est rien
passé comme toi puis s'arrête
soudainement plus en plus graves à
salade extrait extrêmement de celle de
poser un diagnostic dans ce que laisse
la personne arrive
glaude l'outil puis de savoir d'où ça
vient plus de savoir où city après tout
s'il est l'expérience de la douleur est
subjective l'outil d'une personne à
l'autre avec la personne pourrait dire
le souffle participent dans le fond son
genou physiquement presque rien versus
quelqu'un qui dirait baixanencs confort
mais qui est quelqu un problème qui est
sérieux puisque c'est ce qui est qu il
ya beaucoup de choses que tu dis mais
c'est ce qui fait notre job eco c'est ce
qui nous drive à vis de ceux des savoirs
temps à grains comme des détectives dans
polisse mai de 12h pourquoi t'as majeur
qu'est ce qui se passe si je disais
qu'est-ce que qu'est-ce que c'est fait
ça et c'est ces mouvements de la bouche
comme se démocratise ça c'est ce que je
me lève le matin péter j'écoutais un
autre pas de carte que tu as fait puis
vous parlez beaucoup
à quel point si finalement la douleur
qu'on sent prêt pour la douleur cécile
cerveau qui l'a créé le deuil un signal
quitte un signal qui arrive
puis le cerveau décide est ce qu est ce
que vous êtes après ce signal comme
comme la douleur ce que ça vaut la peine
que que je fasse ressentir au à la
personne la douleur type pour toutes
sortes de raisons que ça principe des
fois on pourrait avoir quelque chose qui
ne pas ressentir la douleur parce que ça
vaut dix qui ont géré assez plus tard au
21 mai mais c'est ça aussi que dans le
fond c'est comprendre le cerveau comment
fonctionne votre job ce taux monte à
pied puis c'est d'ailleurs cette
ressource le sur le podcast parle-moi de
santis nous vraiment la peine pour ceux
qui ont mal qui veulent un peu plus sans
savoir
c'est une heure une heure et demie avec
ariel qui parle de 10 qui triple la
douleur fait pour les gens sont une
ressource vraiment cool pour en savoir
un peu plus parce que les gens souffrent
si on parle de deux lames et celle une
souffrance pour un paquet de monde fait
que d'être à la recherche de l'origine
exacte de la douleur
pour nous autres et notre drogue est
capable de finalement aider la personne
après avoir mis le doigt sur la raison
réelle de ces cinq ans avec un paquet de
monde en ce moment qu'ils ont mal et qui
ont abandonné la recherche de solutions
parce que c'est difficile de trouver le
bon diagnostic mis un paquet de monde
qui ont été traitées sans succès qui se
content d'avoir mal c'est l'arthrose est
un des meilleurs exemples d'un autre au
genou de 55 ans et plus s'est auto
condom c'est normal à bord mal auto
genou j'ai de l'arthrose important
l'arthrose chez romain 346% des gens un
sentiment de guillaume exact 50% des
gens une personne sur deux qui est pas
mal en présence d'arthrose fait qu'un la
trousse pourquoi tu aurais mal fait
qu'il faut juste encore une fois
chercher la cause exacte des symptômes
pour arriver à la traiter parce que
souvent justement qu'elle compense de
lokeren et qu'on dirait dans l'esprit
c'est comme si réversible condamné à
mort marge en normal tout de ma vie je
me suis blessé indique t on je me suis
blessé au dos quand j'avais 30 ans puis
j'ai eu mal tout ça m'a marqué ce que tu
dis là parce que mon voisin qui a acheté
petits étaient factor a mené il fait un
faux mouvement s'est blessé le dos puis
apprécié était consultant depuis psy
était pas si vieux le quelques mois je
me rappelle le soleil devait avoir une
cinquantaine d'années puis après ça ça a
été là pour toute sa vie ceci est un
autre exemple c'est ça ne produit que je
me suis fait preuve d' à régler au
secondaire qu'avait dit à quelqu'un qui
est vain et à avant il y avait fait un
concours de pôle up avec son amitié et
puis j'ai eu un goût qui s'entraînait
paul c'est vraiment avec le tout d'un
coup de mal à son corps de ferme axe
polop c'est amal pips temps le plus
faire de pollock puis après lafarge plus
forte mais aussi prêt à la main qui eux
ils vous gardé des patients qui arrivent
parce que dès qu'ils ont ressenti la
mine à face à lézat stressé il le
fallait qui arrive aux professionnels
puis d'autres mondes qui ont mal pendant
vingt et tapis ni fond noir faudrait
peut-être que je consulte type kia qui
procrastine aussi d'aller d'aller
consulter que ça doit être ça va être
l'heure ça va être tellement dur à
défaire apprécié quand ça fait mal
j'essaie d'acheter que je t'écoute est
choqué mais premièrement - en décor 10
de monde qu'ils se condamnent à voir
mais parce que ya 20 ans ils sont pas de
mal puis ils sont dix n'ont jamais mieux
c'est à peu près 80% de monkey island
c'est des gens qui ont ce g histoires
qui finissent tout temps ils finissent
par tomber sur moi d'une personne au pis
on arrive toujours à aider ces gens là
ouais ouais mais il ya plusieurs raisons
présence lors de la première manche
s'arrête le problème c'est que je suis
jamais d'être été un exemple de ce
serait quoi
ben il ton prof ou le facteur commun aux
deux genoux
si on avait traité ton genou proactive
se serait pas améliorée
- traiter ton dos ouais mais si tout le
monde que tu vas voir tu es ton genou ce
qui s'est passé tu te dis j'ai mal au
genou je condamne à avoir mal je
vieillis encore tc 60 radio café ou une
irm fidèles ont tous un petit quelque
chose au genou on va être sûr que c'est
ce qui se passe mais elle s'appelle ne
pas être lié à ce qu'on voit et
d'imagerie puis t d'or physique houcine
soya vraiment propres créations
pendant que se retrouve la suite large
la durée de vie des des problèmes lors
du g 20 ans ce n'est pas un prédicteur
d'échec c'est fait deux semaines
notamment ça fait 20 ans que tu as mal
c'est pas un producteur d'échec fait que
ta blessure musculo squelettiques et pas
nécessairement plus grave parce que ça
fait vingt et un tulle
en mai c'était motivé à changer de façon
générale il ya pas de tout il ya un
scoop pour réduire qu' aucune
blessures ou douleurs qui ne se guérit
pas c'est en jardinant tôt moi c'est ce
que je dis pas ce que l'on connaît les
exceptions mais c'est une blessure
musculo squelettiques bien sûr le
physique je t'aime blessure physique de
régime physique
c'est pourquoi les petits clins d'oeil à
ce sujet parce que on se préparait à
vendre à en disant qu'elle mon petit zay
pourpour rentrer dans des termes super
complexe qui va le monde la physio pas
ça reste accessible à tous deux non à
tout et d'oreilles puis t2 on enseigne
puis moi dans mon enseignement de ce que
je trouve difficile quand je me
renseigne et puisque j'étais important
qu'en genre 500 dirhams au début le
définir peut utiliser après ça tout le
temps sans que le monde attendent à 6
min que ça veut dire dans le jargon l
udemo musculo squelettiques
mais même si je débutais aujourd'hui
dans cinq minutes se rappellera pas
quand je disais mais ont pu aider tout
est ce que ça veut dire
gta like parce que si on exclut mettons
commotion cérébrale une commotion
cérébrale vont nourrir la récupération
chez certaines personnes ont parlé
tantôt de facteurs psychosociaux
c'est dur de définir le thème facteurs
psychosociaux sans parler du nord
pendant une heure au dessus mais on
pourrait dire la relation qu une
personne a eu avec la douleur
si on veut simplifier parce que plaindre
il ya plein de relation des fastes fait
qu'ils connaissent et brûlant dans votre
entourage des gens qui ont l'air d'avoir
plus mal que ce qui devrait des gens qui
ont pas la douleur restait d'avoir
masqué c'est d'abord mettre à part des
tentes où ils sont dans le corps l'air
d'avoir mal justice fait mal je pense
que c'est quelqu'un que c'est la faute à
quelqu'un ce sentiment bref les facteurs
psychosociaux c'est vraiment le facteur
premier qui va nourrir raté récupération
yolain vis de tantôt et un conjoint ça
t'aide les facteurs négatifs c'est les
facteurs psychosociaux
puis dans facteurs psychosociaux et
aussi des fausses croyances par exemple
ben si j'ai quelque chose sur mon irm
c'est sûr que j'ai mis toute ma vie si
j'adore c'est quelque chose de brisé
dans mon corps qui est irréversible la
douleur c'est néfaste
j'ai mal à mon genou il est peu question
du traitement d'eaux usées mon genou
problème une croyance qui serait erroné
dans certains cas
mais sinon c'est exclu tout ces facteurs
tout ceux qui ont des soucis physiques
devrait récupérer presque à 100 % sinon
à 100%
pire job c'est de des délais ariel s'est
spécialisé dans les patients
problématiques qui ont des relations
avec le blu ray qui sont problématiques
c'est tout le monde dans notre équipe
fait sucer jusqu'à lui c'est son dada il
enseigne mais c'est notre job de rendre
les gens qui ont des problèmes physiques
et avec d'autres problèmes de les rendre
déco simple c'est pour de trop facile
mais c'est sur notre objectif et vous
trouvez à faire
la psychologie hamas dans votre vie
roulent sciemment je dis non on est
obligé de se faire former par des
psychologues pour interagir de façon
adéquate mais on fait pas de
psychothérapie de loin de lui c'est pas
du tout l'objectif de nos interventions
mais on est capable de dire que 50% des
gens qui présentent des facteurs
associés à la dépression voient leurs
symptômes disparaître en cours de
traitement physio fait que l'impact est
impressionnant douleur la douleur
physique expliquant qu'une expérience
dit piles et les troupes de dépression
ben c'est à dire que les ouvriers est
pris en charge le fils d'avoir un
diagnostic le fait d'avoir une relation
parce que je suis la personne à peu près
la 3e plus intime avec mes patients à
très mettons les parents que les
conjoints fait que le fait d'être
décidées dans un des symptômes de
dépression etc est une personne qui
prend ce qu'on doit cette relation là
peut être le maintenant dans la règle
ses problèmes avec la relation positive
avec les problèmes physiques
c'est juste en dessous ces étudiants ont
été faites par des psychologues ont fait
pas puisque thérapie on n'a pas le choix
d'agir de façon adéquate
est ce une formation qu'on apprend grâce
aérienne à murcie de maurienne en partie
mais qu'on est obligé d'apprendre par la
suite parce que c'est vraiment compliqué
d'interagir de façon adéquate avec un
individu camara puis quand tu disais que
toutes les blessures se pouvait se
guérir excepté les exceptions est ce
qu'on parle aussi des blessures
traumatiques com
et maintenant
une cassure dans le bras un tendon
d'achille qui cloche ce qu'on parle de
ses blessures lui aussi est ce que ces
blessures le peuvent revenir tous à 100%
si l' architecture d'autres encore pas
été modifié ok factice te promettons
tendon d'achille déchirure complète du
tendon d'achille
si on compare ce qui ont été opérés ceux
qui n'ont pas été opérés
il n'y a pas de différence sur la
fonction met une petite perte de force
quand même facile effectivement une
structure et change de façon
significative tu peux t'améliorer mais
devant une certaine limite
ton corps est pas identique elle cite
pas été rattachées ci avait été
rattachée qui fonctionne de façon quasi
normale c'est impressionnant ok pourtant
c'est bien quand tu vois les images d'un
tendon d'achille qu'il arrache l'essai
une des choses les plus terrifiantes au
monde c'est pas à ma mère roussey oui
tout à fait en plus toi parce qu'on
partait mes parents genre pour leurs 60
ans et on dit on amène toute la famille
au pérou faire un voyage de randonnée
des deux semaines de randonnée de marche
c'est de ma faute parce que genre j'ai
jeté mon excuse bref on recule de tous
pis le taux des sites qui pore pu dans
le milieu la lune un peu particulière
ces infections dans le milieu d'une rue
un peu banlieue métier à temps parce que
là la rue pont bleu chez vous ou chez
castel non avant qu'on parte au pérou tu
es un mois avant pis le sait pas quoi
faire avec lui puis mes parents
n'étaient pas loin fait que je fais avec
vous comme je peux venir nous booster
hugo que ce soit ben omar al arich mais
avait pas de tous soit qu'elle arrive
genre en vélo club mais on va pousser le
taux j'osais des tipis le pouce l'auto
claque à ce que si les gens allaient
crier pilat fait partie témoin le pense
je penche pour être poussé mes haricots
plats voulait repartir le genre a envie
à vélo jusqu'à n'ont finalement le tir
on savait pas quoi mais ça m'a fait
rentrer contester ce pilote est
justement la sellette au périple à
l'avis des spécialistes et à 10 mois
dans un mois je pars en voyage au pérou
pipeau question que je veux pas que tous
les médecins qu'elle a rencontré il
était comme un pro tabarnak mettait
comme belle literie à la fois que tu vas
partir puis finalement a fait le voyage
marché ce but avec sa botte puissent non
on n'y allait pas ni un cheval va quand
même cool mais c'est que ça peut ne pas
opérer les temps dans la chair ça se
peut que tu fais juste le sessad même
dans sera pas parfait mais si vous êtes
heureux c'est une différence entre des
candidats aide des gens on allait
retrouver une vie qui veut que du sens
pour réussir
c'est sûr que si tout casser l'europe y
reprend un peu croche python pitt joue
du piano ou tu fais une chute de rome
c'est super important peut-être pas de
même amputé c'est tout mais l'argent
mais non tu parviens normalement tout
comme sylvain didot qu'architecture du
corps soit estiment que m
mais la chose qui est sûre c'est qu'on
peut aider tout le monde à reprendre vie
qui ont une source pourvu que l'on peut
améliorer alors qu'il était de vide mais
je m'étais cassé le poignet puis je
pense pas que mon que mon corps a été
modifié
ok sauf qui est encore à ce jour sept
ans on a cinq
ça fait longtemps de tels faits encore
ce jeu auquel je m'attendais push up
j'ai encore une bonne douleur mais
changer une limitation avec mon poignet
droit puis c'est probablement juste of
jamais rien fait pour ce jeu
puis c'est sur brahim est ce qu'on parle
est actuellement voire même à carte
exacte mais en même temps ça me
rapporter dans la ville
en général quand soit faire du yoga mais
si j'y pense et iard parce qu'il ya j'ai
le fait une session de yoga qui j'avais
m'apprend qu'il traîne les séquelles de
cartes avec un mois exactement
csdhi comme ce 60 pieds est conviée
secteur a été modifié parce que tu te
plains même flexibilité qu avant
d'envoyer le père et mobilité exemple à
moi c'est des micros tournoi c'est un
maquereau trop exact on parle t de
prévention vous dit pas vraiment
prévention possible à fabas principaux
canaux de la douleur va arriver mais on
peux t on parlait justement d'aida
position assise mettons une position
assise prolongée durant de travail on le
sait que si le corps est pas fait pour
être dans cette position là de manière
justement prolongé comme ceux mais
est-ce que ce que ce serait pas de
recommandations de santé publique des
acquis maintenant huit heures de travail
à 6 en plus pauvres ça peut pas être
celui somme qu'il y aurait beaucoup de
problèmes seraient déjà prévenu juste un
d'isaac éthique en tant qu' à chaque
deux heures fukaya 15 minutes de marche
ou 15 minutes de jeu pour changer
justement on dit mais le mal de place
le problème c'est que même semaine
création avec deux heures si tu t'assois
dans même poste pendant deux heures
c'est ce qui serait assez pour des
douleurs de québec c'est ce qu'il
faudrait c'est juste apprendre au monde
n'a plus bougé sur leurs chaises
apprendre aux jeunes à se lever une
façon facile de bouger mais connaissent
d'achat et c'était j'ai débuté comme
tantôt était pas un petit peu de
positions comme ça ça doit rendre compte
juste parce que menés en bouche c'est ce
qui permet de diminuer le stress au même
endroit ok puis un le le standing des ce
qu'est ce que c'est quelque chose qui
est légitime ou non on chante comment
cette position c'est comme une
récréation
mais c'était toujours la même posture
debout c'était des boutons bassin super
avancer tous ensemble de bananes bain à
court terme c'est pas super g mais
c'était assez la suite pour son petit
koné tia nette baisse dans le dos ça
c'est parce que tu sais maintenir debout
face à des pratiques ces temps-ci témoin
mettant un des seuls moments que je
pense ou est-ce que tu as une position
qui devient rapidement un confortable
que j'ai mal ces bleus c'est quelque
chose qui n'existe plus dans le monde
dans lequel on vit ne jamais s'y met on
allait voir un shooter ou est ce qui est
quand même du monde est un peu corps des
facteurs juste du mobile pendant deux
trois quatre heures c'est pour moi y'a
rien payer le ticket pour mon genre le
mal en première deuxième innovation
mais est ce que est ce que est ce que
c'est parce que probablement ma position
est pas bonne juste debout comme ceux où
si on n'est juste pas fait pour être
immobile debout de 3h 4h très réducteur
de dire c'est juste après ce truc est
pas parce que théoriquement cite aucun
problème serait capable de tolérer que
c'est quand des problèmes qui
éventuellement typique a pas de
l'hôtellerie kiberlain qui circule un
peu d'attenté premiers shoots étaient
confortables et dernier tu l'étais plus
parce que tu a accumulé des
microtraumatismes de marché de manquer
de marche de marché de 1000 pieds dans
un trou tout allait faire de la rando te
glisser sur une roche qui éventuellement
tu es tout ce cd stress mécanique sur
ton dos qui laisse une petite trace qui
s'accumulent qui font en sorte que tout
dernier show de human 5 éventuellement
tu parles de ton genou avec ton domaine
en randonnée pédestre honda qui en train
de descendre ça fait cinq ans que je
marche quand ça va mal ou je fais mon
évaluation de physio d'un monde ceux
d'entre elles puis je comprends pas ce
que j'ai pu
dix minutes après je pense à mon
d'autriche je modifie la posture le
monde où j'arrête d'avoir mal mais j'ai
un problème dans mon dos qui m'a
intolérants la pollution de boue fac si
je me fais traiter je vais rendre mon
dos tolérant la position debout je sais
pas on va l'avoir mal de boue mais c'est
normal pour toi avec les problèmes que
tous les problèmes
ça y est un fan de muse et qui veut
aller très lente que les festivals du
monde entier
il faut que je règle mon problème de 12
ben plus sain que ceux des mondes qui
cuisine qui font à vaisselle il ya même
que toi qui magasinent c'est me suis
souvent qu'un cachet debout longtemps je
suis en train de me dire j'ai en crise
j'ai juste à place laurier de classe
toute la journée que j'ai mal au dos
leyrit qui rit et jean qui met en avant
sa journée dans le chaos aérien ne
paient que aller magazine v l'après-midi
temps rien qui georges je change de
courir un marathon en fin de semaine du
bûcher du bois tout shenzu puis jeter
moins c'est pas le papa c'était dingue
non plus nous n'allons rien mais oui
j'aimerais que vous gérez actes et moi
et m'a gazé cci c'était mon cauchemar à
20 avant que de divisions que je
comprenne pourquoi des choses à une
chose une fille datant du sport auto des
jeunes l'escapade tac oui j'ai appris
plus vraiment que c'est rappelez vous
que le voyage ni à vous asseoir ya
certainement du bien mais oui moi c'est
un super d'avantagé qu'un point direct
ou indirect une course à l'épicerie les
gens couchés ses paniers d'épicerie
ouais c'est des gens comme vous qui ont
mal au dos ouais mais qui s'accordent
pour avoir moins mal puis mais son
enfant j insiste illuminait le problème
études et d'autres aux harkis c'est trop
droit peut imaginer si thomas qui dit
est adroit quand tes racines de manioc
de garder debout tout à swat est encore
marquée comme ce dos pas droit mais tu
contribues amène est un travail non
factice en 40 ans je répète n'y a pas de
bonnes mares posture c'est vraiment ton
problème avec toi ce que tu lâches et
l'avoir dos rond vaccaro de ronces pas
mauvaise ça soulage quantitative adorant
moitié mettant justement le haut du dos
un peu rompu le bas du dos un peu creux
je ne mentais lordose certains diraient
l'ordre pis il ya un nom pour ce fax ici
on est jeunes que je suis pas le seul
mais aussi que c'est une bonne condition
la lordose à kéké la lordose entre à 611
factice est juste le nom de la courbe
c'est donc mettons moi j'arrive dans
votre bureau puis je me tiens comme ceux
vous dit pas nécessairement d'emblée il
faut corriger sous la courbe des coûts
nous faut modifier ton faut modifier
comme entre l'utilisent pour modifier la
musculature qui est autour qui vont
aider à ce que tu t'offres debout
longtemps que j'étais à fond on sait
comment faso faut que tu vas rider
patton de posture le mouvement debout
debout statique réception postal
c'est pô juste changé posture si on voit
de terence c'est juste que je dis
souvent à mes patients c'est ma job à
moi c'était permettre de faire des
niaiseries donc de te permet d'écouter
un show de quatre heures mais ta job à
toi c'est de faire des exercices qui
vont faire en sorte que ton corps va
être meilleur lino ensemble mais ça fait
en sorte que le ponner quand je revois
ton show fait qu'on va te permettre de
faire des niaiseries métaux surface
certaines choses aussi pour t'aider
londres iiss l'offrons ont grandi le
vase puis on avait un petit hold a aussi
ses grands on a parlé dans le vide
ce qu'ils veulent mais pour grandir la
base enfance c'est comment qu'on fait ça
les facteurs parce que je suis comme on
parle tantôt si on intervient de façon
adéquate on n'est qu'après grandi là bas
parce que la présence de facteurs
psychosociaux pourrait diminuer le vent
mais quand on voit ce que ça veut dire
avoir une plus grande tolérance mans
cette douleur
on peut aussi changer la mobilité la
mécanique pour lui tant d'autres cas pas
de tente et plus pour te garde a fait
dédaigneuse reid
enfin que si riche si ici dans ce que
l'on va pas être de compensation
messidor et une partie qui bouge moins
bien que les autres partis bougent plus
puis on voit physiquement je te demande
de bouger dit en demandant vous défense
des mouvements tu te vois compenser les
petites filles on pourrait prendre
caméra puis tout le monde te vois tout
vendre ça pour ça en plus tu as tu
apprendras bougez autrement que ça
grandit le vase on peut aussi des
interprètes d'exercice pour doucement
partir de tolérance commentant dans la
natation je bats et des muscles et des
tendons
on veut porter à torrance de
désarticulation fine mais si une douleur
c'est même si je mens la tolérance si
une large mesure ce parce qu'un problème
quelque part qu'il faut régler ce jeu
par exemple une simplification c'est à
cinq vertèbres lombaires pour avorter 5e
vertèbre lombaire qui a eu les
microtraumatismes dont tu parlais tantôt
qui françois kaboul - bien qu'en des
deux bouts mais tu vas être obligé de
bouger un petit peu plus ailleurs parce
que tu veux être debout facta colonnes à
votre donner ce que tu veux être de boom
est un ver thème la 5e vont moins bien
bouger ben jones avait de restaurer le
mouvement normal la cinquième pour kepu
de compensation par les autres autos
compensation qui néfastes
c'est la différence avec tantôt
l'accompagnent la compensation est
rarement bénéfique fait une job à nous
c'est de modifier les propriétés
articulations autorités notre team
muscle au travail à façon d'utiliser ton
corps puis qu'est ce qui se passe parce
que tu justement d'en porter si
j'écoutais on se rendait compte que la
corrélation problèmes physiques douleurs
et pas tout le temps direct le
financement est est ce quelqu'un il ya
quelque chose d'ensembles mécaniques de
son corps qui fonctionne pas bien
adéquatement qui ressent pas la douleur
qu'est ce qu'on fait avec ça on peut
rien qu'en février
y'a pas de prévention possible on a dit
tantôt à exécuter habitués c'est des
fois en course à pied on parlait du
genou qui rentrent par en dedans ou
typique s'écrasent et se gagnent chacun
marathonien je vais sur deux sont sur
son nom un africain équipe shaggy voilà
merci je répondis la mort comme ceux ci
sont pas tendres course
selon des experts et aux icônes tout
croche et pourtant il ya plusieurs
records du monde
acte antipatriotique on n'est pas bien
de changer mais je me gêne que c'est
pitt y mettons parce que la douleur est
un signal c'est sociale qui lui dit
qu'un jour qui fonctionnent pas
correctement ce que je corrige
c'est un signal qui dit c'est ton
cerveau qui pensent que si tu continues
pour être deux et c'est avec ce signal
d'alarmé qui dit attention si tu
continues il pourrait y avoir un
problème c'est le beau dire qu'il y est
mais vous rencontrez rencontre était pas
dit qu est ce que le le système d'alarmé
la douleur pour fonctionner correctement
la personne a développé un problème sans
s'en rendre compte ça doit arriver
les gens qui se serait blessé comme
physiquement sans s'en rendre compte
ouais outil qui a man était à la longue
je suis parti un mouvement que faisait
planer au fil du taillon plus aucune
mobilité dans l'épaule ou dans je sais
pas quoi te met you put le signe
avant-coureur you put le plus la douleur
associée à ceux qui font que c'est juste
un story graduellement piqué la personne
n'est pas les consulter parce qu'elle
avait pas mal mais elle est quand même
mieux maintenant est quand même limité
une limitation mais quand je rentrais
salariaux dans votre texte
harry hole mais tu vois la différence la
secte est en train de parler d'un
mouvement observable qui pourrait
nourrir à la personne la personne
devraient se rendre compte que son
épaule les plus et une fois qu'elle se
rend compte que son aile son épaule
l'efs plus elle décide de me faire
traiter son premier fax et la décision
de personnes de ne posera à traiter dans
ce que le fait que la prévention
la prévention c'est un peu comme je
disais tantôt c'est fait ouais traiter
quand tu constates que tu as un problème
puis que ce soit de la douleur ou juste
une orientation direction des douleurs
pour simplifier mais beaucoup de
difficultés à utiliser un mot qui
définit ce qu'on fait mais il n'y avait
pas que non tu viens de voir sans
douleur parce que y ont perdu de leur
fonction de leur capacité à faire
quelque chose qui fait qu simon relève
publient aucune douleur mais je veux
qu'ils lèvent bain et les gens viennent
nous voir nous faire swing de golf
adéquat je te capable de cinq ans je
viens de recommencer mongol capable je
m'en viens de voir si on le fait c'est
ton exemple que chercher à 10 j'ai
quelqu'un qui n'a aucun symptôme aucune
limitation observable mais quelques yeux
c'est microtraumatismes et qui laisse
des traces le la fonction altéré qui
crée pas de limites on n'est pas grave
de prises et qui vont avoir mal plus
tard parce que fait ma fonction
une fonction qui est pas normal puis ce
serait de la colonne des problèmes
meilleure façon de le voir parce que
c'était cinq vertèbres lombaires aucune
des communes bouge mais à partir du
moment où tu en es là dedans qui bouge
pas bien tu t'en rends pas compte mais
de dire autant une qui bouge pas bientôt
pas mal mais si je la traite ça va
empêcher le vent mal plus tard c'est ce
qu'on ne pourrait pas de dire mais c'est
une limitation observable il se pourrait
qu éventuellement certains plafonds
peintures avec ton exemple des pôles ta
douleur sur toi
radieux que dans ton quotidien 0-2 lors
au poignet mais si tu commence demain
matin à faire quelque chose d'important
pour toi qui nécessite un mouvement du
poignet pour avoir mal plus aujourd'hui
j'aurais donc dû consulter avant le jeu
prix après capable de faire mieux demain
matin avec ma blonde allait me berce
mais quand même avec gross rajouter déjà
qu'une voir ses passions mannequin puis
inversement mais ton légèrement d'un
scénario inverse de quelqu'un qui aurait
des douleurs mais est-ce que c'est ce
que ça se peut qu'une douleur soit 100%
je sais pas comment tu t'appelles ce
psycho somatique ou une somatisation
comme une création totalement une erreur
du cerveau mais ça il n'ya pas le pain
notamment problèmes physiques
ben oui c'était il ya intérêt à ce que
j'ai accepté de la somatisation qui est
l'expression physique d'une souffrance
psychologique on n'aura pas beaucoup
dans nos bureaux de ces personnes là ce
qu'on voit plus c'est des gens qui ont
eu mal puis il existerait des neuro
tagle des neurones qui reste facilement
activable par le cerveau de mal à
l'épaule le neurone responsable de ton
épaule on simplifie dans ton cerveau
reste allumée de plus mal à l'épaule
mais tu vis un stress au travail cité
par deux tableaux ton cerveau va
utiliser préférentiellement le neurone
qui est facilement active en dessous de
mais d'avoir mal à l'épaule depuis le
problème à l'épaule lui été réglé
mais non le vendre et 7,6 fixé ce qu'on
voit plus dans nos bureaux fait des gens
qui vont avoir des douleurs qui sont
modifiées par les facteurs psychosociaux
par le stresse pas été par la crainte de
quelque chose la guerre avec et evra
l'action volvo beaucoup moins jeunes
disent c'était un petit problème
physique mais qui a amplifié beaucoup
par quelque chose d'autre que j'ai bâtie
chorier c'est absurde at a time âneries
mais toujours un petit quelque chose qui
est drivée par d'autres choses mais que
sa partie mais ça finit super gros avec
cette sensibilité-là de la douleur est
aussi modifiable ou pas des fois dépassé
c'est quoi une personne qui plus à plomb
se mettant hypocondriaque
est-ce qu'elle a plus de chance
d'aborder développer des douleurs
notamment un peu de sa rendre compte
être au contact c'est peut-être une
hyper vigilance active un peu de
symptômes mais si grave pour toi c'est
comme n'est vraiment pas ça avoir maté
mois qu'il ya peut être un petit et un
confort pour toi c'est très grave
sb ce repas plus quelqu'un d'autre qui
clique et décrit les problèmes pas
nécessairement sur mme descamps voir un
petit problème elle ça va être un gros
problème c'est ce qu'est la nuance mais
à voir sortir pour de vrai groupe
ces pages sont exagérées c'est moi qui
vais même auparavant bureau puis je dis
j'aime à 9 sur 10 ou 10 sur 10 g
croissant pour ça je crois qu'ils
exagèrent je pense qu'ils ont vraiment
dur qui t'est chabot de leur monde sait
que c'est vrai cauchemar qu'est ce
qu'ils vivent
ouais parce que leur perception change
de la douleur dans le fond c'est une
perception piste la perception est à 9
sur 10 sinon exactement je crois que
tout le monde qui me saoule ouais on
présente une émotion
ouais c'est ça certains frais dire cela
pourquoi je vous comprends bien jeter
une invention du cerveau le bloc 1 puis
moi j'aime dire mais patience et au
dessus du jeu déjà vu de l'amour tout
déjà pu l'emporter de l'amour dans une
boue et pourtant ça existe la douleur
existe elle est réelle mais c'est une
émotion au même titre que l'amour fait
que comme c'est une émotion bien c'est
vraiment variables comme si c'était au
tour d'une personne à l'autre
ces modules et par un paquet de facteurs
mais c'est une expérience les droits
c'est pas quelque chose qui arrive quand
tu penses quand principaux de la douleur
c'est un stress mécanique sur ta peau
que ton cerveau interprète était écrit
l'émotion qu'on appelle le droit
c'est une sensation agréable puis est ce
que ben j'imagine que oui j'imagine que
il ya beaucoup de monde qui c'est le
fameux mind over bodied ou est-ce que tu
réalises qui aimait tant la douleur
n'est qu'une émotion était comme
capables de la bloquer c'est ce que
j'imagine que
il ya des gens qui sont plus sont plus
aptes à faire ce que d'autres cibles aux
petits hedge d'être capable de pousser
plus loin dans des efforts physiques ne
tombe
je prends un exemple d'une chandelle si
on a une durée de 6 depuis on est
l'exemple puis on may have heard achats
d'avions à dessein l'entraînement on va
tout enlever de demain à un certain
moment parce que on va avoir mal mais de
aïn dheb rudy fait qu'on n'a pas de
vision tank adverse et un système dame
nature oui dit elle je pense que si tu
continues tu pourrais être dans le
trouble
puis ça se peut qu'on admet à
différentes autant 6-2 dans la
plantation tout le monde un petit bord
feux entre le signale à robson puis il
ya vraiment quelque chose qui peinent
dans ton corps étaient souvent les
athlètes de haut niveau
ce beau période il est presqu'une ya
presque rien que de pousser et même des
fois tu peux te blesser dans tes
performances me demande tu poses ton
corps c'est très tentant pour les
sprinteurs ses côtés des muses que
mettre ta mère mon niveau mais puis il
ya des gens que tu as fait vraiment trop
gros puisque nous sommes pas une trop
souvent ici sont bien trop tôt ou tard
oui tu peux tu peux te rendre vraiment
proche proche proche proche proches la
jeune et complexe il y en eu c'est une
expérience le dehors quand jamais eu
d'expérience c'est parce que celui-ci se
serait vu les vidéos du joueur de
basketball qui atterrit pis castétis
biopile des pieds pendant le guide
oui 5 secondes avant de comprendre ce
qui se passe 02 02 là une expérience il
l'avait jamais eue avec lui quand il a
atterri effet il s'est passé quelque
chose d'étrange au chili oui il fallait
qu'ils voient que celle constatée comme
un problème le procès s'est dit fracturé
fracturé en savoie pour ben ma carrière
j'ai moins c'est mon frère c'est pile à
la douleur mais que le cerveau peut ne
pas comprendre suite quelque chose déjà
est un vrai douloureux ou détruite un
traumatisme mais pourvu cet épisode à
savoir si à ce que les 103 points que
que d'autres choses
j'imagine que la douleur est arrivé
après 15 ans d'exil et les légendes
urbaines aucune femme s'ouvre une auto
pour un seul pour sauver son enfant
souffre reste saari pauvres
mais est tout petit laid après elle le
fait pauvre parce que si t'es pas de
mécanisme qui te dise arrête de forcer
pour soulever un auto soit le faire top
obama la capacité de le faire mais
normalement c'est le propos pour pote
cassé en morceaux puis de tout déchirer
mais ces gens le font c'est c'est
incroyable je reviens encore à mon
histoire d'aider des nageurs qui font le
marathon la trace du lac saint jean un
mes amis xavier desharnais est arrivé
deuxième
il a gagné deux fois un bill hader fois
que les huit arrivées deuxièmes citant
des vagues ce genre c'était incroyable
puis un quelque chose qui est impossible
or c'est impossible de faire ce sens
arrêté puis il en arrivant et 10 pour
les dix derniers kilos avaient des
craintes d'un double icipe des deux
quads mais monsieur madame tout le monde
l'équipe en une grande gare est de
marcher son ami ses tripes sont à terre
puis c'était répliqué qu'ils portent pas
de grand boum j'ai pas fait dans le cas
d'une grande je pas en train de faire
leur tabarnak
je sais quoi mais lui pendant dix kilos
il y avait des crampes des daims quatre
membres et apprécia évidemment la
semaine après était pas un top shape
mais j'ai juste continué alfort team
c'est qu'on perd sur la douleur
effectivement comme un signe assez
intéressant tu peu sympathisé avec tout
ce qu'ils font le marathon de montréal
qui sont plus ou moins feat
je pensais couru pendant quatre heures
pendant cinq heures de temps c'est la
force du mental pour georges laraque qui
qui qui est parti a fait deux fois le
marathon de marianne vieillie partie les
deux fois en ambulance à l'avancé mais
le il va être plus en forme sa défense
ebay à free de cesser maintenant
qu'est-ce qu'ils aient qu'est ce qu'elle
avait dit le médecin y avait dix genre
tu as failli mourir mais prête à son
niveau est habitué de dieu ma limite à
moi c'est ça je me fixe pas alors c'est
sûr mon objectif un piti j'étais un peu
ce qu'on fait avec nos patients aussi
quand et la réassurance compte pour
beaucoup dans nos interventions parce
qu'on veut donner un diagnostic qui
tient la route pour que les patients
comprennent ce qui arrive pour qu'ils
arrêtent de s'imaginer de ceux qui
condamnaient avait fait que la
réassurance compte pour beaucoup un les
athlètes et pour l'un des hôtes au
réassureur
ils ont regardé par je n'ai qu'une
crampe m'en fous quand je venais la
compétition deux semaines après c'est
fini et auxerre qui se fait c'est d'en
face ce qui va avoir mal il quand même
jusqu'au ko facchetti jobson ils savent
que deux semaines après son collègue
ouais mais l'avortement keita puis moins
c'est ce qu'ils peuvent plus payer deux
choses soit qu'ils ont moins mal parce
que c'est moins dangereux pour eux moi
est un peu moins pire option numéro un
le numéro deux juste habitués de tolérer
de woippy peut-être aussi que laure 10
est il qu'ils connaissent mieux leur
dise quelqu'un qui pense qui est à 9 sur
10 mais qu'au final ils étaient trois
sur dix moutons non il est vraiment neuf
sur dix sept personnages mais c'est
parce que si mettons cette personne le
one en combraille comprend mieux
maintenant cette personne-là avait vécu
un 10 sur 10 le peut-être que locke il
pourra même douleur a très peu 9 après
le réaliser ouais ou ton expérience avec
la douleur est complètement différente
sont habitués de la gérer ça fait partie
de l'obligation quand ce genre de niveau
le tunnel top ultra marathonien attend
160e kilama était pauvre et comme la
rose
non non non non non surement peau
dernièrement je me suis blessé en
arrière de la cuisse puis j'ai fait
noyade pour ce puits dans les jours qui
ont suivi quand ça quand ça allait mieux
puisque je le sentais plus j'aimerais
encore une crainte
chaque fois je m'en aller courir
l'acheter comme je courrai plus grands
qu'ils ont ils seront chères contre un
gros chèque c'est good deal le simple ça
c'est une réaction normale j'imagine que
oui cantonne canton une douleur d'une
blessure pleut comme le le phantom pink
apple qui quittent comme l'impression
que c'est l'homme et ses pulls c'est dur
à savoir c'est encore loin ces deux
affaires différentes ce qu'on appelle
des sites avait une hyper vigilance
c'est tout à fait normal tu viens tu
viens de te blesser on est en position
de ton cerveau est en mode était plutôt
en mode alerte
puis plus sensés être des petites
affaires texte est une chose qui
ressemble à ça il va te dire plus tout
et je me fait mordre par un chien si je
recroise de même chine souhaite avoir
plus peur c'est une réaction normale de
survie maintenant fenton payne c'est
chez ge amputer les gens qui ont perdu
tu es donc j'ai perdu mon gros coudre
d'avoir mal au bon que dos pu - avec ses
deux enfants tombent assez la douleur
est ressentie
c'est par le cerveau est dans ton
cerveau tu m'as tu de ton corps quand
poupée vaudou puis à peut-être fait à
main ben tu as évolué en date est allé
encore un drop et demain donc du pakao
formelle au brouillard est ce c'est
bizarre pic qui fournissent ends
qu'est-ce qui fait ceux ci dessus parce
que c'est un petit peu la douleur
préféré qu'on parle tantôt que peut-être
deux mâles ailleurs lui qui pense qui
perçoit le signal de temps mais qui est
coupée souvent il ya eu des expériences
douloureuses importante avant
l'amputation aurait plutôt eu mal juste
avant l'amputation plus l'empreinte au
niveau du cerveau est important c'est
que ce que le savoureux santi agne
employés continuent à le ressentir
il y en a qui veulent se grattent il ya
plus de recoins
il veut se gratter corps qui ayant
l'impression que ça c'est une sensation
très inquiet tout et puis moi on aurait
mais on put breux fait que c'est autre
chose malgré ton comportement façades
blanches gantés retourner courir ce
comportement est normal parce que tu es
tu allé courir il serait pas normal
c'était pas à les choristes avaient pas
osé facto
de façon progressive de l'aude et au
dessus de façon sécuritaire et je savais
que tu étais pourrait arrêter si c'était
pour faire mal
c'est un comportement sain je t'avais
retardé d'un an c'est encore un
comportement malsain il faut s'attendre
à des gens que tu qu'on voit un bureau
qui arrivait un an de lens 5 1 comme le
prologue de tantôt acteur c'est
dérangeant c'est passé tout être
affrontée d'amis ni peur mais citons
tactile est pas français ni par deux ils
passent encore marché suggère fait des
pilotes sont finalement sadien cercle
vicieux parce que la plus mon activité
physique entraîne s'est plus entraîné
plus de douleur 10 dans le monde est là
dedans petit rêve jamais trop aimé
laffon vaincu le cancer qu'annoncera mal
donc sur comment ce pot me dis jamais tu
recommences tu as mal fait un méchant
nous sommes vraiment aux gens rentrés
nancy j'appelle ça le cercle vertueux
sont à chaque fois je suis là chaque
fois je fais d'hommes s'écoute on les
encourage à bouger de façon sécuritaire
assure une expérience positive
puis la petite bouche tu puisses te
remets à bouger petit peut reprendre
habitué aux particules si tu t'en chez
vous et emma et c'est parti comme ça
c'était moins mal actu peut recommencer
de pencher pour ton cerveau diminue
larmes tellement c'est quoi le tir avait
dit les gens qui bougent pas assez les
gens qui bougent beaucoup
c'est comme ceux qui se blesse c'est
quoi la proportion mettons de votre
clientèle est ce que c'est plus des gens
qui bougent moins c'est plus des gens
qui bougent et qui sont blessés avec en
faisant du sport
ma cliente s est passé avec les gens qui
consultent en physiothérapie mettons
qu'on veut je jase l'épidémie doubiste
on pourrait dire facilement que la
population générale fait pas cent trente
minutes d'activité par jour dit l'ong
on pourrait penser que ben plus de gens
qui sont pas suffisamment actif dans
leur quotidien notre clientèle
c'est la note est composé un peu plus de
jeunes actifs que des gens actifs mais
il y en a qui sont spécialisés sportifs
qui ont juste du sporting qui ont eu des
blessures traumatiques plus probablement
que la personne qui est sportive au plus
le désir de régler le problème peut-être
août et pour pouvoir parce que ça allait
vraiment un impact direct sur ses
performances mais tombe sur quelqu'un
qui aurait une douleur mais qui pourrait
nuire à sa qualité de vie mais
l'atteindre et peut-être plus longtemps
avant d'aller la règle est terrible
c'est encore drogba sté la qualité de
vie pour le désir de vouloir performer
comme sportif donc été de vivre ton
désir de voir qu'une éthique ce soir ça
peut être similaire pour deux personnes
avec fait autant motivés peu importe qu
est-ce qui que ce soit sans personne à
mal dans le dos dans son divan qui
voudraient absolument qu'on va rendre
plus avoir mal de dents doit travailler
à 6 pandémie zoom sur le pavois roma
c'est important pour tout à fait que je
pense que deux catégories ceux qui ont
pas le désir de changer ouais nous
aurons tout va et des puits la majorité
des gens ont le désir de changer sur qui
en a qui ont des comportements inadaptés
tu veux changer mais des comportements
face à la douleur sont inadaptées fax et
ce qui est plus compliqué pour
reprogrammer
je n'irai pas un physio parce que je
suis convaincu qu'ils pourront pas
m'aider avec -12 et sopi mais comment
ces gens d'autres annoncés dans votre
bio ils se font en guinée ils cheminent
il ya un ami qui leur a dit il mais si
j'ai mal puis j'ai fait le choix
d'essayer pis si ça te coûte quoi cette
côte au rendez vous puisque vers eux que
ce qui vaut 10 points de base au dessus
de redonner de l'espoir en leur donnant
des diagnostics qui tiennent la haute
chambre de comprendre et de prendre en
charge mais écoute
on en a plein des gens qui n'ont jamais
osé consultés avant que je te donne une
chance je veut bien de moi comme ceux
justement peut-être qu ils vont s'y
croit pas à l'efficacité du traitement
ils vont peut-être moins dans ses
dérives ont ils vont peut-être venir
vont se former pour les prendre comme du
monde doit leur donner une chance
d'avoir un succès si on fait rien comme
du monde pour les pour les pour modifier
cette perception là on les condamne à
l'échec
celle où nous autres on s'est fait de
former pour être capable de prendre
cette personne ne peut la mener sur le
chemin du succès elle pour augmenter ses
motivations puis j'imagine qu'ils n'ont
pas pas sans ces personnes là aussi
qu'ils vont chercher des réponses
ailleurs m des fois même ailleurs que
dans la science la magie mais ça aussi
j'imagine que vous devez vous battre
contre ça des fois les fausses croyances
des gens puis ça dépend à quel point
est-ce que ça a contribué à leur
province quelqu'un croit qu'il ya une
aire de croiser dans le coup le destin
l'a considéré coûté paralysie c'est
cette loi fait toutes les fois où est ce
que j'ai entendu âgées un air de coincer
damphousse eu raison de parler
exactement
c'est une façon de parler d'acte et j'ai
peut-être pas une batte contre cette
croyance est personnelle et ne concerne
pas ceux des fois c'est juste pas
comment dire que tu as mal avec tu dises
est attendu en arabe je pense d'une
vertèbre déplacée
ça se peut non plus si c'est que c'était
acceptable sous état d'urgence d'accueil
syndical puis theater de coopération
active avant de dépasser un arrêt coincé
si c'est juste une station des régimes à
des tumeurs des fans mais c'était sûr
que c'est simple être absolument il faut
que j'aie décoince puis il y avait
peut-être une dette une croyance qui qui
fait que tu peux pas écrire tant ses
portes place et la salle informatique
depuis deux ans on peut vouloir
challenge cette croyance parce que les
gens doivent soit reversé temps un peu
autodiagnostic j'ai seulement problème
c'est ce jeudi que google me le dise
il vous faut que vous rivers et
ingénieurs du seul tir de la base on
apprend on est vraiment seul domaine de
la santé où les gens croient qu'ils
savent faire comprendre cardiaque de
l'autodiagnostic est sur le coup j'étais
le diabète au dessus choisis ton
médicament toi même mais quand un
problème physique musculo squelettiques
si vous décidez d'aller sur internet
puis de trouver un programme
d'entraînement pour toi même
basé sur ton auto diagnostic fait que fx
effectivement un problème mais ils sont
venus dans notre bureau
il a confié que je reconnais pas dans un
centre d'achats en train d'essayer de
convaincre sont déjà ce qui en fait le
mot pour diriger confiance ou bien tu
sais ce que je fais mike peux tu m'as
aidé si ceux ci sont les gens qui
croient qu'ils croient pas à la physio
sont razi leur ticket si vous êtes l'an
dernier j'ai plus de choix de gérard
guenat fils a par exemple fait que tu
aies après doit jaraï teutons on avait
même une opa 5 on aime énormément le
guide commotion cérébrale puis j'aime
boire deux commotions cérébrales
je te lis partout ailleurs à 20 parce
que chaque vie que ci dessus mais des
poches des condamnés drôle de réduire
tout ce qui est venu de voir avant
qu'ils vont sûrement pas marché la
pression je finis quelque chose qui fait
accuser mais des fois les gens font ça
parce que ça faisait un physio c'est ça
rit ça fonctionne et nous apprend un
certain temps puis j'ai entendu de quick
fix et joints et beurre mais je dirais
moi aussi je tirais contexte où le
montage est wikileaks pourquoi
maintenant des fois quand je préfère pas
de quoi passer de vampires on était
peut-être d'autres ctg fret du monde au
chauffage jugé fin 2011 mon seul
problème j'ai mon garage c'est réparé
mais atlanta veut pas exactement comme
cela puis une williams apprend des
efforts de la personne blessée
je sais maintenant que tu te donner une
liste d'exercices à faire la maison faut
que tu effaces sinon il ya pas de
solution permanente - six ans de quoi on
est capable de faire des coûts fixes on
n'a pas d'états des métis tu es vraiment
attentes et objectifs offrant estiment
être un petit peu
si ce que c'est notre job pour faire
comprendre ça aux patients général si on
fait notre job comme seconde des
patients vont faire ce qu'ils ont à
faire
si c'est quoi les ventes aides et les
techniques ou des interventions vous
faites le titre des exercices que les
gens doivent faire la maison vous vous
devez manipuler aussi les patients un
peu puis il ya eu d'autres choses c'est
quoi maintenant le lac tdc qu'est ce
qu'on fait quand une décision est en
avance ou c'est aussi pas mal ces deux
essais c'est bien c'est d'aimer ça reste
à préciser qu'on passe d'ailleurs s'il
ya un million d'exemplaires données
majorité ce qu'ont fait nos mains mais
bien vite gezin rose a passé une journée
samedi passé avec notre équipe a
enseigné sur le traitement des mères
juste les nerfs fait que c'est un des
tissus dans le cas sur lequel on peut
intervenir manuellement et avec des
exercices
c'était le co2 il ya eu un courant avant
texte on peut sauter ces techniques le
contrôle approfondir vraiment pour
chacun du dessus fait que c est ça reste
simple jeu que te décris visuellement
c'était à côté de mon cas je travaille
là dessus c'est la complexité derrière
on parlait du travail et d'encadrement
donc factures ou plutôt le diagnostic
main précieux sur ton coffre à outils
qui occupe toutes les pièces ici faut tu
trouves le meilleur outil fait que ce
qu'est notre job s'il faut trouver dans
pologne comme du monde puis après se
trouver le meilleur outil pour te donner
les résultats de souhaits j'imagine que
si mettons la source du problème à
personne c'était peut-être une mauvaise
habitude un faux mouvement
mais j'imagine l'exercice elles servent
à régler les fonds mouvement mais
j'imagine qu'il surveillait et des
recommandations d'habitudes de vie vous
devez faire aussi aux gens voient bien
même si mettons tout est faux mouvement
des dix fils de mao douleur après tout
ces problèmes mais ça se peut que tu
avais un d une moins bonne mobilité sous
jacente qui en fait c'était un
précurseur est baissée soirée s'est
passée à menacer de m'habiter d'heure
pour prévenir les récidives
par la suite et pas exercice à comparer
toujours sur deux fronts
on améliore tant qu'actuel puis on
s'arrange pour que ça arrive entendre on
peut pas faire de prévention comme on
disait tantôt mais une fois que mal on
égale à 2 dit pourquoi tu as mal qu'est
ce que tu avais à 20 pour que tu es mal
la majorité des patients qui viennent
nous voir on traite pas là ce ce qu'ils
ont fait que leur ont fait mal on traite
ce qui était présent un vent qui leur a
permis de leur faire mal
les gens ont super mal puisque 10 km
soit femme change ma droite je suis tu
feras pas guérir mon dessus paraison
juin modifie ce qui est à l'origine du
stress mécanique soit au dessus et la
guérison va pouvoir reprendre
mais on est tous ces bons à traiter en
aigu quand le patient vient juste de
commencer à warm up et à 14 sur dix
comme quand ça fait dix ans que mal
parce qu'on allait encore une fois les
différents outils pour intervenir à
court à moyen et à long terme visant à
mesure de leur dire ce sacré la drogue
et l attaque tête dans le futur fait
plus et puis c'est ouf et le moyen
moufter ou fait des exercices jusqu'au
point que je te dis est ce ça va servir
de prévention non parce que tout va mal
ça qu'on sait quoi faire pour buter mal
c'est la nuance est qu'une fois que mal
on sait quoi faire pour but est mort
dans le coffre à outils puis l'éventail
des choses moins
ce thème c'était multi factorielle ma
blessure derrière la cuisse que manger
gens survenue mais une des affaires que
je me suis fait face l'acupuncture c'est
une pratique qui est courante c'est
quelque chose qui est bon qui est parce
que moi je sais pas quand grandissant
j'avais un préjugé comme l'acupuncture
pour une raison que j'ignore
complètement aucune idée comment cette
arrivée le fait que ce qui est qu en est
il de se mettre d'eux avant toute chose
il ya des aiguilles sous le terme sûr
qu'on ne sera pas juste des idées
étaient dans les muscles coin sûrement
cette révision bref faire ou
l'acupuncture qui est basé pose à
s'élancer sur la médecine chinoise
traditionnelle qui est te dit toto de
kiki comme une énergie vitale qui
conviendront d'aider des méridiens puis
surtout de certains points que voit ce
que ton énergie à bouge moins bien que
tu veut débloquer avec des aiguilles
vertes notamment de ce sera peut-être un
peu ésotérique se résume à pied et
conditionnel juste pour ce serait
peut-être un petit peu et eric comment
est-ce que ça s'appelle l'éguille soul
edf est ce qu'elle est lui issu le dong
hwa été déduits des copies ce qu'est ce
qui se passe quand ça arrive parce que
moi dans le fond l'aiguillette aller
loin et aller loin jusqu'à toucher l'os
de mon bassin puis qu'est ce qui se
passe quand une série que tu penses qui
se passe
j'en ai aucune idée peut-être cette
pression s'était aidé ben en fait je lis
il y avait plusieurs ces seules affaires
c'est que c'est plus plurifactoriels
fait que je ne peux pas dire mais parce
qu'il y avait des manipulations un petit
souci parce que c'était comme un système
mon muscle qu'il y ait le fessier
jusqu'à l'arrière l'accusent dans le
fond puis plusieurs manipulations plus
se faisait que conforter le jetez plus
loose métier c'est se situent les
tueuses pas bien définies parce que
l'aiguillé de ce que j'ai compris que
j'ai pas fait la formation mais ma
compréhension c'est que comme deux
objectifs visés le premier c'est
diminuer l'inflammation en lien avec la
libération des médiateurs de
l'inflammation avec l'aiguillé fait que
30 en aiguille une réaction chimique
le deuxième objectif ce serait de
changer la tension dans le muscle fax et
c'est là toute la différence de ce seul
acupuncture changer l'énergie l'eau
c'est pour changer attention dans le
muscle fait ton feeling est censé pull
loose m a complètement raison puisque je
te demande était
un tas croyances va affecter son
résultat fait que j allais quand même on
peut demander à ce que mon physio eshop
exactement il m'a aidé plusieurs fois
l'at il faisait qu'on vient voir si ça a
aidé à rebours de résultats mais dont 7
à sensation de louche c'est ce qu'on
vise avec les aiguilles en général sauf
que de tonus musculaire
c'est quelque chose qui change
rapidement dans ce sens stricte je suis
je ferai de mon mieux ce qui devient dur
géorgie devient mou d'un an travailleurs
ceux ci on peut travailler à pourquoi
tondeuse musculaire est à base c'est un
risque de revenir le mâchage que j'en
états du sud vers les manipulations
peuvent s'adonner musculaire et le froid
le chaud que tu sais pas qui veut faire
je dois une fière l'aiguillé ce qui est
honteux c'est ce diable de sentiments de
profonde que le massage
je veux pas mais ça reste des traces y
ont passé la court terme
s'ils s'inclinent finalement être
thérapeutique ou est ce que tu te remets
à bouger tourna court et ça va mieux
fine mais si tu il va à chaque semaine
tout faire faire ça plus de baser là
dessus puis c'est quand même certaines
répétitions chaque semaine ça c'est
moins hot de tirer des aiguilles option
mais justement c'est ça je pense que
c'est vraiment l'espace deux fenêtres
que tu parles à court terme qui m'a
permis de remettre en place d'aidé
pratique d'exercices qui m'ont aidée sur
le long terme parce qu'ils se rappellent
donc je t'aime plus qu'avant marché chez
nous ce genre j'avais une douleur
tellement et gül puis puis ça a fait
clic en shorty de la première fois se
braquer manche qu'il y ait des
mouvements capable de forme c'était
uniquement kim kim était recommandée
pour me remettre enfin sur le sur le bon
chemin surtout la même chose si ce n'est
qu'après une façon d'avoir des fenêtres
d'opportunités pour créer un changement
effectif des cuisses en est une la
manipulation qui sont en études latines
le comme marielle massage ça peut en
être une
y'en a qui vont de la chaleur l'idée
c'est de changer raison du bouge il ya
plein de façons d'y arriver
pour que ton exercice qui est prescrit
de façon adéquate en fonction d'un
diagnostic tide par la suite un fait que
certaines personnes ne sont pas capables
de faire des exercices a déclenché un
dollar du fait des interventions qui
modifie le tonus
puis après sur son capot de faire leurs
exercices qui leur amènent finalement
leur récupération mais devient une
intervention qui était pas en
monothérapie qui était postule c'était
combiné à d'autres interventions la
littérature suggère que c'est la
meilleure des choses hors monolithes de
chaleur justement pic de froid moi j'y
vois une confusion là dessus parce que
je ressens que chaque fois que j'ai dit
dans ma vie j'ai mal quand même au 10
mai de la glace ou mais la chaleur mais
que c'était tout le temps flou c'est
pourquoi c'est fou parce qu'on ne sait
pas on ne sait pas dans le sens où il
faut que tu utilises succès du billet
pour toi et les gens qui sont plus
sensibles au froid qui doit être des
fois ça va faire mal et les gens votent
pour cacher sa vapeur par marc ses
dépenses après coup de soleil je prends
une douche d'eau chaude phrase faisait
partie des blessures on va partir comme
ben et surtout strech têtes raides à
glace mais peinait de plus enregistré
des pics de chaleur mais encore une fois
c'est une règle du pouce puis je vais
pas te donner un kyle hines précis pour
soi mais est-ce qui est ce que c'est
purement placebo lorsque la cie
justement cdc erap ok ça me fait du bien
ça me botte bien ou c'est vraiment un
effet c'est ce qu'à la recherche sans
penser aux exactions qui a pas de
recette particulière qu'est ce que tu
aimes puisqu'ils sentais de plus à un
fax de la croyance y en a plein de sons
qui jurent que par la glace le mot la
glace à chaque fois guichemerre la glace
contenu moi j'ai la charge
parfait j'aime penser la glace ce qui
est pas de règle des cistes une entorse
lombaire 6-3 6-7 shopi c'est exaspérant
ses bases sur les croyances personnelles
la personne qui te le dis il se base sur
la personne qui lui a dit l exacte et la
formation qui commencent à voir le jour
là dessus justement pour changer un peu
les mots de pratique mais ça fait
longtemps que deux autres ont dû aux
patients choisissent qui tide parce que
l'on n'est pas vrai de dire que ça aide
ni l'inflammation ni la douleur de façon
certaine
est ce que c est ce qu est ce que si
nouveau que mettons aussi cette
information au look est la recherche est
rendu le husa dans le monde
la santé puis de la physiothérapie ça
tout le temps été un peu connu que ça
mais dans le public qui est ce justement
ces dix idées fausses croyances après
enquête avant que la littérature seront
sur le plancher des vaches à
l'université en mai travail de fin de
session est à vous c'était les
étirements
mais à l'époque le 21 c'était connu que
les étirements ça fonctionnait pas
prodigué permanent mais aujourd'hui les
gens s'étaient encore les gens se tirent
encore avant de pratiquer une activité
physique en pensant que ça prévient les
blessures les gens c'était après
l'activité physique en pensant que ça
change quelque chose
il y en a qui mettent des vêtements
compressifs en pensant que c'est quelque
chose qui m'est et qu'il est le terme à
la fois de construire
ok là ce qui est justement soit souvent
des produits des dix experts des
domaines pis ça arrive tu es con qu'une
croyance qu'on a qui est pas du tout la
réalité nos métiers on a reçu les
dernières semaines pythie grosso modo ce
qu'est ce qu'on parlait j'ai appris des
choses mais si ce que je passais ou ce
que je les recherches que l'aef est allé
un peu dans le même sens l'ont déjà
trempé la fois que je vais jamais
entendu le trieux mais fait qu ils
l'étirement - l'étirement sert à quoi
puisse piquer sais quoi qui est qu'est
ce qu'on pense que ça fait quelques qui
ça fait pour flins
l'étirement va changer tactics visiteur
peut temporairement affecté ici moi je
m'étais bien évidemment je vais être
tous sur surface dure pas longtemps pour
rester sur faut toujours cette série
voilà rio peut-être quitté les études
ceux n'ayant pas été faite sur 15 ans
non plus n'est peut-être qu'une gymnase
était depuis 15 ans il sert elle s'était
par un attentat c'est aussi souple on ne
sait pas mais quand c'est à des muscles
celle attendue à plus 98 compter sa
grande époque
plusieurs études ce qui change en cette
séance n'est pas la longueur de ton musc
c'est la tolérance de dans le cerveau à
tenir et étirements les deux là ça
change ta douleur à l'étirement ne
faisait pas plus mon profil bas depuis
on tire dessus
même si on était vraiment fort il veut
pas s'y risquent d'être parle
nick et tutoie le muscle le filet de
porc
effectivement je mettais par la barben
mais si tu n'es pas dans mes cuisses ce
pas eux qui rallongent juste mon cerveau
qui dit à mon corps au quai qui peut
desserrer un peu plus loin tu peux pas
être chez plus haut à terre quand même
des gens qui est sion qui sont pas
capables d'une presse qui était son nom
de la complètement un blog qui est un
bloc de glace là tandis que d'autres
ultra flexible tenu ce midi tonus
musculaire toi aussi le deux types de
collagène dans tes muscles puis des
proportions différentes chez des gens
déjà qu'ils ont des ducs un tissu dans
les articulations peu sûr que d'autres
naturellement et aussi au site est déjà
conquis par la kz hyper sexy fait il ya
deux solutions génétique ou si il ya des
restrictions ne sont plus articulé aussi
accepté ton article donc bouge moins
bien mettons que je tends d'ordre
tactique me sont totalement au repos by
antho la cession à fait juste pour
bouger du monde qui ont des raideurs
articulaires hocine mais sans pansement
de muscle s'est tenue ce musculaire qui
est dit qu'ils peuvent être passés de
genre relaxe apport lac ce qui change
tout explique t fait ton étirements le
bénéfice premier puisque logique je me
sens mieux quand je m'étire fait que
celle démontrée puisque une bonne raison
de continuer cette série pour la
majorité des gens qui gardent une bulle
qui s'étire avant de défendre sa
performance s'est associé à d'aspersion
puis la croyance je me suis toujours
attiré puis ça me rend meilleurs
continue d'être moi je me trompe
vraiment là dessus d'un certain support
est à noter qu sibilité sécurité désiré
aba'a passante et que tu vas voir peut
être excité par un court laps de temps
fort impact en asie qui a besoin d'aidé
d'état jambes fines besoin qu'est ce que
tu faisais part court laps de temps ne
connaît pas encore été de se dire j'ai
la forme et ont maté le chômage et
menacent tout aider des gens qui que la
flexibilité vais partir d une ballerine
outils pas que vos parties intégrantes
de l'or dans leur sport sont plus
flexibles moyenne des ours nains ont
redonné deux jours les effets de
l'étirement sambi dix paires
ou commencé à disparaître après deux
jours fait ton effet maximum
immédiatement après mais ça décroît
rapidement fait et quand tu disais
tantôt foot et c'est toute ta vie mais
il faudrait que c'est à dire aux 48
heures c'est un maximum d'intervalle en
aux étirements toute ta vie je te les
maintenir des liens tout le temps à
moins d'être différent enfin quand grand
faute au système nerveux central chez
certains individus te permet d'être
vraiment souple parce qu'il contrôle au
tonus de façon adéquate
je ne serai jamais une gymnaste bon
système nerveux central
mais mais une limite amont tonus je peux
regarder d'autres chanteurs mais gildas
ont pas le même système de douche
centrale que moi avec les études à cause
de l'entraînement à coup senti comme ça
tu sais tu commences à 4 1 c'est
difficile de répondre à cette question
le mais si on me dit c'est les gens
minces ils font du jogging les jambes a
aussi il fonda musculation on est attiré
vers ce qui est facile la gymnastique
moi jamais attiré gibeau souple mais
peut-être que ça attire quelqu'un qui
est souple je progresse de répondre à
cette question la savoie ce qui modifie
sur chez un individu à ambazac en
commençant jeunes ou site et attire
naturellement va soudain côté bon c'est
complexe que même réponse que je l'est
pas mais sinon l'étirement ne prévient
pas les blessures vraiment le sport
l'étirement pourrait faciliter ton
activité physique
si tu prévois une performance sportive
deux jours après une performance
sportive
genre tu copies toujours courir dans
deux jours ton étirements pourrait
diminuer terre courbatures postes
entraînent mais je prévois courir dans
tous au jour des tirs et bosser rue
jarry il y aurait une dimension de force
social étirements exclu que parler du
joueur alors qu'ils tentent aussi que
triton gardien de but qu'il faut qu'ils
passent d'un bar du filet à l'autre bord
le plus vite possible quand c'est le
temps bâton étirement au le potentiel
des dix minutes et performances en
termes de force fait que tu te tires à
20 mètres un potentiel d'être un peu
moins fort mais c'est un gardien de but
de la lnh à perdre de forces n'est pas
significative mais pour un
un jeune joueur je serais curieux mois
de l'entraîner puis de ne pas utiliser
des étirements mais plutôt utilisé le
terme ans chez eux
mais préalablement à une partie du rock
et d'utiliser des exercices qui prépare
le hockey en performances plus ternes
fait pas des étirements avant
performance plus des étirements chez
vous à examiner 10 15 minutes afin pour
être capable quand même avoir le style
papillon comme dit mon pigeon hypothèse
jamais validé mais c'est ma croyance
personnelle base sur ce que chez des
étirements de ce que je sais des les
coureurs y ont des des routines très
course pour préparer la course le
préparer ton cerveau l'activité physique
fait de façon générale dans les
échauffements c'est ce qu'on cherche à
faire faites moi si j'avais à faire un
test je prendrais d'y jouer à rock et
j'ai fait cette série du joueur à qui
j'ai fait passer de série je leur donne
une routine en place chez vraiment que
curieux de comparer les performances
je vais pas comment je mesurais les
performances philippe cette série un
trou de variantes 2010 cette série après
le sport qui se pourrait réduire mettons
le lien le côté là qui captera qui a
appris à connaître dans la presse aussi
dit ben ça changeait pas grand chose qui
est démontrée savaton coude en
feuilleton retour au calme l'étirement
est souvent faite dans l'espèce d'esprit
de de retour au hockey mais c'est
important d'avoir cette période après le
sport pour prévenir je trompé les
étirements ne préviennent pas le la
couverture que l'espace et c'est le coût
d'entrée c'est ce que je me trompe et
anglo saxon warrior dans l'échauffement
avant le sport prévient les blessures
qui t'ont retour au calme le coup landes
après le sport prévient les courbatures
après le sport extrême préparer une
activité physique deux trois jours plus
tard mettez mieux de faire un cooldown
puisque bofa le cooldown où perdure et
traquer métropole et pas plus à risque
de blessure prévention des blessures ou
à mains nues et que si les gens qui nous
écrivent en âmes et moi je m'étire pitié
après ma course ça me paraît pas traquer
ben ça s'peut pas ce qu'on prend des
étudiants mét en comprend 100 personnes
puis on dit vous 50 et et vous vous
inquiétez vous pas après la course puis
organique erratique ibaraki mes yeux du
monde pour qu'ils étirent marc savard a
étayé de nos prisons sa bonne nuit
comparé au groupe tu fais rien mais si
on prenne moyens
ça change rien mais ça se peut que ce
soit différent pour différentes raisons
de santé croyant souhaitons système soit
différemment ça peut aider
avec sa taille de feydeau mais on veut
pas de sujet à tout le monde passe en
moyenne ça change rien tantôt pas encore
dans le dé de déconstruire certains
noirs de mentionner prendre et il est
nul comme étant une opportunité d'ouvrir
une fenêtre pour pour réparer un
problème mais est-ce que admettons que
je lance un scénario peut-être que je
dois tourner n'importe quoi le corrigez
moi si je dis n'importe quoi admettons
que l'inflammation qui crée un
frottement dont 1 1 mu qui qui qui est
influent mais pis que ça fait au
quotidien continue est informé par ce
qui accroche quelque chose ou xy raison
est-ce que 1,1 à devises mais ton qui
est un anti-inflammatoire peut servir
dans certains cas de solutions qui vont
permettre de guérir le problème s'il n'y
a pas d'autres mesures mises en place
mettons les bons souhaits juste parce
que c'est compliqué toute chose mais
premièrement lior aucune façon d'avancer
mais c'est un fait d'armé c'est encore
une simplification
un peu comme une gêne à la cuisine exc
l'internation n'est pas de
le mal du siècle moteur physique
proposons une inflammation de bien
comprendre l'inflammation c'est quoi
c'est la présence de produits chimiques
relier l'inflammation valide en
laboratoire dans un tissu ce et
l'inflammation qui est taillé dans une
tendinite ça durerait quatre jours dans
les processus de guérison normaux ça
pourrait durer jusqu'à sept jours après
ce théoriquement y ait plus
d'informations mais le système
immunitaire se met de la partie et tu
peux avoir de l'information à cause de
ton système immunitaire c'est vraiment
compliqué avec l'information sont des
produits chimiques qui sont le camp qui
au bout
/ ou kurde anormal de façon habituelle
de second pas loin quand on est un peu
déçu mais pas seulement c'est une
douleur vraiment d'une blessure ouais
comme détenteur d'émotion c'est juste
honteux que ce n'est un impact il ya
plusieurs molécules que si en fait c'est
un peu de tonus au microscope ou si on
met des positions et d'amples il ya
plusieurs écueils qui peuvent compléter
l'information qui est différent titre
d'information aux-in puis de saint
brieuc sont des moments depuis ta bien
sûr puis des entrées at war ils font
juste comme les adultes vont sauter un
titre d'information ces mêmes poker que
prendre mais en tout cas tout comme un
homme très déçu c'est même pas que
prendre des anti-inflammatoires aide à
guérir sa à cette occasion ses
ressources naturelles qui peut être
bénéfique
même si thomas accès à arrêter
complètement
c'est pourquoi que c'est mieux mais je
veux je veux donner une piste à ta ta ta
question
ce que tu voudrais faire en fait quand
thomas s'est arrêté d'avoir mal et peu
importe le moyen de surprendre parce que
ton cerveau
il est allergique à la douleur parce que
ce qu'on a dit tantôt c'est qu'en
présence de dollars dont son cerveau
craint acquiert des façons de tuer ton
corps qui sont néfastes possiblement
sérieuse de temps 12 avril aux attentes
au vote
la solution la meilleure quant au mal
c'est d'arrêter d'avoir mal sauf que la
meilleure façon d'arrêter d'avoir menacé
d'arrêter de faire ce qu'il fait mal
qu'est ce que vous faites quand
seulement la première des choses vous
vous étirer et vous fait encore plus mal
comment la couture est étiré pour avoir
encore plus mal en pensant que ça
soulage
parce que l'étirement veux te soulager
de façon temporaire mais ça risque que
tu viens d'étirer tablaient sur 5 le
meilleur comportement présence de
douleur c'est de faire immédiatement de
prendre immédiatement une position qui
enlève tes droits
ça va être plus efficace que ton entière
fut un temps où est-ce que tu de plus en
plus d'évidence que les anti
inflammatoires vont mettre à l'entrée de
guérison facussé pis pour ceux qui
parlent et ils veulent volontairement
parce que le tylenol
c'est pas un ancien commando fax est un
analgésique flexible pas bête de prendre
un analgésique en présence de symptômes
parce que ça dit à ton cerveau pendant
j'étais pas mal
qu'est ce que tu souhaites en réalité je
transforme ta question c'est si j'étais
capable de faire quelque chose pour
enlever ma douleur immédiatement
effectivement tu serais capable de
guérir et de pas avoir d'effets à long
terme sur boumsong en puissance et ça
vient si c'est toujours une réponse plus
complexe que de prendre et le met en
exergue les problèmes mais dans mon
corps
parce que je sais ce que j'ai quand j
man la plupart du temps mis du leur
volume de biens parce que je sais
exactement quoi faire immédiatement fait
que ces faits sinon si on veut cacher
quelque chose de plus grave
1 puis souvent la deuxième question qui
m'est précieux c est ce que si je
promets de senad juste de masse qui me
dois plus me blesser
la réponse est non
certaines ne s'est pas assez fort pour
arrêter se pose pas une injection dans
l'agefi qui te j'ai quand même accroché
deux dentistes coin mais actionnaires et
divise cette gêne pas assez pour le pdc
entend rendre compte si quelque chose
qui est à deux gardes tu veux sentir
actrice ça sert à rien de dire moi je
prends mes pilules parce que je
resterais pas merdé sait plus où j'étais
sûr que ça ce que j'avais mal 30 et puis
ça fait du bien
ouais bénéficie plus grand de sa trempe
opus était jeune souffrir ouais c'est ce
rêve d'enfant dit quand ce qu'est ce
qu'on dit avant qu'on se laisse qu'est
ce qu'on dit à nos auditeurs qui mettons
ce serait quoi le conseil numéro 1 si on
commence à sentir la douleur c'est quand
qu'on décide d'aller voir quelqu'un
c'est quand qu'on veut c'est de venir
vous voir c'est quoi mettons le pour
potes dans les trop longtemps dans le
sens inverse c'est quoi le c'est quoi la
règle de poche pour se défendre
moi je dirais la t6 c'est la première
fois que tout ce que tous leurs deux
premiers bobos
tu peux attendre sais tu pas tendres
puis le doigt de leur dignité
normalement si un malade voire préparant
une fenêtre que deux là ne descendent
pas dans le concept leur ton corps a
besoin des aides pour compte l'a guéri
c'est quelque chose qui les empêche de
guérir
enfin que même si c'est la deuxième fois
que de mal mais c'est à dire que tu as
déjà mls en toi qui font que ça va se
répéter et l'autre me consulter c'est
une semaine
vous risquez pas d'admiration ou bien si
c'est à 2 impact sur le bien si tu es
stressé de savoir que ce dock puis à
duarte est inquiète id ou si tu veux
guérir rapidement parce que rapidement
le jeu des faits cités ci fais ci fais
pas ça fais pas ci fais pas ça pour
permette à un taux de 2,2 fois son
travail le plus loin possible pour une
desserte réguler une des sources
physique parce que je peux je peux dieu
ne peut pas rendre la petite digression
plus vite et sont encore peu faire mais
ce que je peux faire c'est de dire fais
pas ça qui va retarde d'état grison
lésions physiques mais souvent les gens
viennent nous voir et on paye d'autres
maillots peu d'accidents c'est une loi
greipel progressivement mais quand cette
année puis c'est pas mérité nouveau tout
il ya pas de mauvais moments
si ça peut être le lendemain de
l'apparition des symptômes ça peut être
la même journée si c'est important pour
toi il n'y a pas de douleur trop petit
pour être traités mais garneau qui
veulent pas nous déranger qui veut pas
prendre rendez-vous parce qu'on passait
mal ça existe pause parce que tu t'en
doutes l'afp à l'epa ou le sponsor mais
il se peut que je te permets juste pas
tablons de ce coup sûr tourné pour le
soir venu
même si c'est important pour toi c'est
important pour moi et c'est pas parce
que tu as essayé avant tout là pour
fonctionner
c'est pas parce que tu es désespéré qui
a pas de solution c'est pas parce que tu
as de l'arthrose qui ait pas de solution
fait s'il n'y a pas de mauvais moment
pour consulter si tu as envie de changer
c'est possible ou une question si je
vous dis aux jeunes âgés au point un
plan mais non vous dit tout ce que
j'avais annoncé que l'on jetait sitôt
c'était tellement facebook n'a pas
fonctionné toi tu dois avoir une autre
vision passait pas tout épisode sans
pareil tck mlabo vegan y aura d'abord il
ya la moins bonne raison que des mauvais
physique de mauvaises bové gamme ça
existe au maroc il ya des mauvais tout
des mauvais podcasts et des podcasts
beau matin il ya des mauvaises physio et
des confusions et t il la même relation
qu'avec un qu'un psy si le psy tuque et
pâques tombe s'ils votent avec ce n'est
pas le bon faut pas voir un avocat
c'est le travail qui est fait aux
dirigeants vont avoir un autre type de
venger celle acquise au sein parce que
jérôme à sonia prime diffusé aux
différents pays citons la bac aux
apôtres notre avocat c'était ça la
question a fait pis ça pourrait sûrement
vrai sûrement partir longtemps là-dessus
métier la personne qui a mal des fois à
se poser question je vois requis ou
avoir un physio le voir un qui roule
avoir un air goujat voire un ostéo jean
voirin la sauge avoir entre équipes i
télé la distinction entre un vélo des
fois est pas clair pour beaucoup dont
pour moi pourquoi qu'est ce qui
distingue mettons la physio tu que six
maisons c'est quoi la physio
premièrement c'est comme comme science
qu'est ce qui distingue des autres pim
et on sait maintenant qu'on connaissait
de distinguer un peu ces différentes
disciplines
on a combien de temps pour savoir le
temps qu'on veut la physio c'est une
science à santé c'est la seule issue de
la faculté de médecine musculo
squelettiques un fait qui permet aux
gens la seule tu veux dire la seule
science de la faculté médecine qui focus
sur les visualiser les autres sont dans
d'autres aiguë et lison crois que j'ai
nommé le maintenant il y en a plein qui
sont pas universitaire là dedans moi m'a
fait les physios piqueyrot c'est la
seule université les autres cd formation
post-graduée rgo aussi mais on accuser
la physio on s'occupe d'eux les gens qui
ont des bobos physiques on s'occupe des
idées a retraité de vie qui veulent nous
on travaille dans deux cliniques privées
où est-ce qu'on a souvent juste des
douleurs physiques mais plusieurs
branches à fusion pas que sportive
natation mais je vais prendre deux
minutes pour répondre métayer décision
dans deux départements precepta ya
fusion la fusion en oncologie studio
après et après chirurgie il est idiot
pour les grands brûlés la physio projets
qui font désormais ses décisions pour
des cadeaux respiratoire que beaucoup de
fusion mais ça sert aux bobos physiques
c'est maintenant la direction pilote à
faire la physio on a une vue de ses
puces je dirais bio psycho social à dire
biologique on est prêts on a une vision
mécanique du corps effective si tu
bouges comme cela s'appelle du stress et
des hommes et si je change tout
mouvement ça change ton stress et de se
tuer nous n'avons pas de début on a
aussi la vision qui est plus des
croyances des émotions leur violente
dada personne que c'est ce qui définit
la fusion de se jeter pour ça non c'est
la question c'est comment je fais pour
choisir on a pas pire des billets au
moins physiquement
si on pensait pas qu'on était la bonne
solution vous arrêter dans l'autre on
aurait été en fait on devrait changer de
domaine parce que si on s'était rendu
compte qu'on n'était pas légion on
aurait changé de domaine est là le
problème
en fait dans le jouet dont tu parles
c'est que tout le monde est capable
d'aider les gens moi c'est ça je
convaincu que que tous liés les
disciplines que j'ai nommé il ya des
gens qui retirent des bénéfices exact
fait que trop de gens peuvent être aidés
par un paquet de personnes différentes
maintenant ne job à nous comme physio
c'est d'essayer de battre le placebo
lundi pentu rappaz démontré qu'ils sont
supérieur au placebo
c'est vraiment cool ce qu'un fonds de
recherche ils font des fausses
d'aiguillés d'acupuncture pense cartonné
grimés lieu à des vies ou aranda mousse
fine in patients des compteurs pense
c'est une vraie ou une fausse aiguilles
puis ultimate de bonnes études il n'y a
pas de différence entre la tossée grippe
devrait guye king quand qu'on considère
que c'est pour jouer avec le chili on
comprend mais oui mais l atrium les gens
vont juré que le placebo soit parce que
si ça traîne on s'en fout exact c'est
toujours sur le truc effective
comment faire pour choisir y est
l'élément croyances fait que si tu ne
crois pas à quelque chose est loin
d'être désespérée envers quelque chose
que tu crois mais c'est une bonne note
et pignons batterie nous autres on
considère qu'on est
les mieux positionnés en termes de
savoir puis de capacités d'intervention
pour aider un patient musculo
squelettiques parce que on a à la fois
l'aspect physique pinasse vers même
psychologiques dans son chaudron de
discuter de facteurs psychosociaux
on pense qu'on est capable d'offrir la
solution pour l'immense majorité des
communes que los que l'éthique on est à
l'aise à dire que tout le monde devrait
récupérer en l'absence des conditions
tantôt ce nom parce que tu es on prend
peur et pendant une heure le pharmacien
est insuffisamment épisode là dessus sur
la masse au 2t opi l'acupuncture à part
le mot de santé encore il ya interviewer
machine au podcast en moi de santé qui
est super bon qu'un interrupteur
d'experts différents domaines
en santé il était détaché par rapport à
ceux avec pour apprendre différence
sinon la chiropraxie rapidement c'était
je joue je vous dis de façon à moi est
biaisé possible la philosophie initiale
5 tonnes d subluxation vertébrale qui à
terre d'influx nerveux qui épuise les
organes innover par leurs intérêts
deviennent douloureux ou malades
l'accès c'est au début du siècle c'est
ce que le fond attendant d'attaquer
roissy retrouve trouver comme façon
d'expliquer pourquoi ces procédés les
gens sauf que maintenant on sait que
tout ce qui est tout à terry yake baisse
de la paix est pas vrai il ya aucun des
200 ce qui était prouvé que ça se peut
si ce que moi j'ai plus à dire qu'ils
ont précisé qu'ils regardent une langue
qui ne jure que par ça et c'est une
étude en alberta qui ont fait tant à
voir tout et c'est wade qui rôdent
alberta puis elle dit encore une
personne sur trois qui me mettait sur
son site comme quoi ça fonctionne
il ya loin d'être encore plus tard
feuillus qui disent qui est temps que le
nom donné à nos organes
ils peuvent aider des affaires comme des
troubles d'attention les déficits des
activités du meurtre de medicare et
qu'on sait que ça se peut pas j'ai ce
problème là que les gens qui disent
qu'il faudrait comme ça mais par contre
un bon tir haut qui est qui connaît les
évidences qui veut pas juste faire
pigeonner pacistes à se séduire
l'auditoire ce registre a craqué mettait
plus de leytron par semaine
tant qu'ils endossent à nous auto s'ils
en faisaient
mais c'est la philosophie derrière s'est
située juste de refaire pour autant
passif moi je suis moins pour ça mais si
toi tu es pour être un passif que
j'attende comme ça c'est ce qui était
vrai dans ta vie ben on peut faire un
physio mon peu souffert pendant qu'ils
roulent mais qu est ce qui fait qu il
quelque chose qui aurait été démontré
comme étant mes scentifique mans jetait
les bases vraiment sont peu solides
comment ce devient une des enseignants
university flamand bonne question
nokia intérêts de la profession il ya
des chicanes ce seuil des associations
de kerho commun en angleterre qui ont
enlevé ça dure c'est toi qui dis oui on
sait c'est la d'histoire mais on sait
que c'est plus vrai piges je peux fait
de jeu par qui aurait mérité une ligne
avec sa trompe guère les époques et
sertic actuellement mérité je pourrais
faire une blague
les bancaires au fond de fusion une
pourquoi le système musculo
squelettiques
il est pareil chez tout le monde ouais
parce que moi je me suis fait suivant un
parent qui rocchi qui est au rouge en
aussi puis je vous ai tous qu'on parle
depuis tantôt puis même maintenant ce
que je fais avec
avec mon physio ça ressemble vraiment
beaucoup halle était super il était
support qui connaissait dit le corps
complètement il savait quel quelle
musique / rejoignez ou psy jeune joueur
est il vraiment une musique qui va
tendre le type extec ce qu'on dispute en
a tous un peu sur le tri plus des
manipulations que je fais pas chez mon
physio ton prof hsbc revient ce qu'on
dit il faisait de la fusion parce
qu'encore une fois ci on si on dit que
c'est la seule profession issue de la
faculté de médecine qui traite de
musculo squelettiques c'est la physio
les sciences médicales
ben c'est en faculté de médecine ben
ce site traite le corps physiquement
comme la littérature le dit fait de
vision parce que les chiros et de la
science chiropratique c'est pas des
sciences médicales
le coc des sciences ostéopathique c'est
pas de la science médicale puis vont
même dire que certaines choses du monde
médical qui sont fausses mais que ça
veut dire
science ostéopathique t la science est
vrai ou appauvrir le thé dansant ce qui
est dénoncé cela faire c'est pas parce
que tu appelles ça une science et
science
je pourrais pas dire c'est quoi la
définition lemay mais pour que quelque
chose soit confirmé comme étant réussi
on veut fawkes a été soumis au processus
scientifique des études des études
scientifiques fait que la majorité des
brevets des prétentions disons un ostéo
certainement kyrou comme l'histoire de
10 tours de 1920 sa part réussi à
résister à l'observation de la science
fait que pourquoi je dis science et aux
pratiques c'est juste parce que je veux
pas dire fumisterie parce que il y en a
qui vont pratiquer comme la physio fait
je peux pas tout les mettre dans les
enseignes puisse à chacun un effet
placebo
ce serait là pursuit qui aiment leur co2
d'entendre des propos injurieux mettons
fait je vais appeler ça des sciences et
sympathique juste pour dire que leurs
prétentions sont rarement fondée mais
c'est leur science art puis le diplôme
en ostéopathie ils font un pseudo dr à
la fin il ya besoin dr au sens et bormes
et ils font des études de fin de l'étude
pour prouver des propos mais c'est pas
la rigueur scientifique on va retrouver
à l'université par exemple fait
qu'encore une fois parce que le placebo
existe parce que si tu crois en la
personne qui est avec toi qui te donne
des propos rassurants brise d'été des
sites à croyances terminal en est et au
hamas ou en acupuncture en cuir ou josi
mais c'est une autre note expérience à
nous c'est que tout ce qui au vu des
échecs ailleurs on n'écrit pas d'idées
c'est quoi les comme étant avez-vous des
pour terminé sur note positive des
histoires des patients mais ton qui
était vraiment mal à manger le petit que
ça les a vraiment ça changer leur vie
complètement en avez-vous je m'imagine
que l'accusé avait que me suis vite
qu'ils étaient vraiment le à l'épaule
c'est maintenant et si leurs problèmes
et beaucoup aimeraient une chaque mois
c'est un monsieur relativement début de
carrière et si je t'aimerai confiance à
montmagny en fait la taxe même si un
excellent travail et qui travaille chez
bombardier doit à l'épaule l'irm est
déchiré à l'épaule puis venez de
reculons par son médecin y avait dix il
faut peut-être la physio traité vous
avez rendu à son chirurgien trop motor
speedway ya réponse adaptée chirurgie
non c'est juste et justin a trace a
surgi qui n'est pas la fusion qui
produit cette douleur puis pour
passagers à bord bâbord à la physio et
en servant à trois mois quand même lui
rendent un peu de recul on finissait
plus tôt chez moi partie affectés bien
quand on est plutôt prix des mémoires et
ça qui arrive t il de l'opération mais
un petit jack est doté d'un éthylotest
processus pré opératoire il arrive que
j'ai rejoint cette aberration chargé des
nombreux élèves sont nombreux ils
passaient d'un bâtiment à bâtiment les
doigts de côté puis 10 / trop bientôt
par toi alors tourner en fusion sera en
deux mois soit rendue
ouais c'est éviter une opération
totalement dans sa décision
puis c'est lui et puis et puis avec les
épices et chirurgicales gratuites à
périgueux jared opérer quand à
travailler puis problème à pied en
relais jeune fille de 23 ans va se
reconnaître si si allez côte
éventuellement parce que
j'ai revu récemment le de 23 ans c'est
une joueuse de ce que puis cet essai
ville sont imposés 4 1 qui était plus
capable de jouer fait c'est pour elle
c'était un échec dans sa vie c'était
c'était très lo apporter d'abord été
arrêtées dans ce creux à cause de lois
tout qu'elle a essayé devait pas
fonctionner c'est une douleur aux
lombaires fait qu'un capable de jouer un
match en est limitée par la loi nombre
limité à ses propriétés pas de jouer
depuis quatre ans et si elle est capable
de dire que j'ai changé sa vie parce que
l arrêté d'avoir mal à son dos et elle
était capable de rejouer ce qu'a fait
qu'elles puissent apprendre ça m'a pris
beaucoup de temps mais c'est juste que
tu c'est le genre de petit miracle qui
sont le fond d'entente parce que il
emotionnellement c'était vraiment
important de retrouver une capacité
physique conforme à une fille de 23 ans
top chef enfin que c'était vraiment que
vous filez m kim et tong pim et on
comprend ce que le piqué ont filmé
processus le dis le à la river qu'un
douleurs de dos comment tu sais comment
comment te trouver d'où provenait le
problème c'est comment tu le commenter
les traiter je crois savoir qu est ce
qui a causé son mal de dos et là on est
formé pour ce factice est ce qu'on
enseigne les deux à la fois l'université
ou en post gradués formation continue
fait qu on est formé pour poser les
bonnes questions pour avoir des réponses
qui nous aident piètre ce faire les bon
test pour essayer de comprendre comment
le corps ne fonctionne pas et après ça
c'est vraiment cool parce que je peux
faire une intervention manuelle
puis voir c'est qu'un changement je peux
enseigner un exercice est immédiatement
mesuré le bénéfice de l'exercice
bénéfices et sur un mouvement très bon
exercice de puma dans ma face pendant
mon traitement fixé après tout c'est
rapides que ce ben en fait mouche à
l'aise dit que la majorité des passagers
50 % de gain à l'intérieur du traitement
de leurs essais sur piste à la fin du
traitement tout droit trop sur 10 parce
que je veux mesurer l'efficacité de mon
intervention à chacun des traitements
fonctionnent de façon facile
manuellement puis avec les îles les
exercices on est capable de modifier les
symptômes
max et je ferai tout ce que je dis
depuis souhaitons tout autrement de
physio d'année dernière fois dans la
façon dont nous on voit la physio c'est
qu'on fait une intervention pour leurs
tests à près de six mois j'haïs aux
échecs pas que je vous assure que tout
ce que je fais est super bon et si je
fais un entraînement puis jeudi était
maintenant comment marche un pas en
avant en trio pour cependant de tous mes
moyens pareils je fais sur 4,5 fois
c'est en cela que si les choses qui
arrivent je sais c'est quoi donc on
ressort pas avec 20 12 2010 mode agile
24,5 à face avec du bien je veux avec
wade quoi comme ça je suis sûr qu'après
une fois j'aurais fait exactement ce qui
a été et des tâches le benchmark comme
moi même pour être sûre que mon
traitement le plus efficace possible
6 à savoir qu'elle manipule avec
quelques et le traitement fait que c'est
le tue c'est à partir de là qu'est ce
qui est en jeu réglage confirme-t-on à
niort exact confirme que tout de suite
une intervention qui fonctionne aussi
comme si on appliquait le pré ce
scientifique que notre intervention tout
le temps acceptons ce souci qui
distingue les chances que je fasse de
quoi les yeux fermés puis de peut-être
attendre un résultat dans deux semaines
sont assez minces merci mais ça me donne
pas de même à dose suffisante de drogue
dont j'ai besoin
[Musique]
merci beaucoup les gars étaient vraiment
j'ai vraiment appris beaucoup
aujourd'hui
ou est ce qui vous est ce qu'on va voir
si c'est votre clinique cic ques et
commencer le temps de dire ça ne demande
rien aux actifs et aux actifs
on est à montréal au complexe claude
revient et à laval un beau brillant à
saint-eustache à boudry tout le monde
travaille de la même façon puis encore
une fois notre objectif c'est de se
satisfaire d'avoir des résultats
mais ça donne des méchants résultats aux
patients ça qu'on est là pour le passé
depuis deux ans un peu égoïste on veut
avoir des résultats
énorme fête pâques en fait d'être
publiés par l'api pourra toujours gérer
mais pas pour nous de ce qu'on peut
traiter des gens sa photo jourdain et
commet trop cérébral les vertiges
étourdissements les fuites et mode
tahiti mais les fuites urinaires et ou à
raison sexuelles et des physios femmes
spécialisées là dedans aussi
l'accident sans compter qu'on compense
moins qu'ils affichent plus crétine et
puis vivement toutes les 12 heures de la
colonne des fois les gens pensent que la
colonne 6 1 professional pilot
transactions traitées dronne pitou
ladlad tout accord nantes et varie pas
c'est sûr
potennerie je pense que poser de
questions mais faut arrêter
[Rires]
merci beaucoup merci d'avoir écouté ses
podcasts jusqu'à la fin de ce pas que
vous avez apprécié la conversation ça
prouve que vous êtes de réelles fans de
conversation et sans fil pas de casser
on vous remercie vraiment beaucoup
si vous voulez voir plus de contenus
plus de conversations sur pétillante que
ça se passe bien sûr peut tuer a non
seulement on met tous les podcasts en
ligne au moment où est ce qu on les
tourne donc on a beaucoup de semaine
d'avant sur le pétrole mais on fait
aussi des encore moins de filtres qui
sont exclusifs au mmm pétulant nous
aussi quand on parle d'homme nicole et
moi de la conversation convient d'abord
parce qu'on met un peu plus en
profondeur dans certains sujets qu'on
voulait aborder ou qu'on abordés pendant
le podcast donc allez sur une page de
turenne les liens vers ses avoirs dans
la description du podcast qui remercie
encore une fois nous avons écouté
jusqu'à la fonte